we're good to go okay um
uh as chair of division three
of the house finance committee i find
that due to the state of the emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
hell
[Music]
um that as a result of the covet 19
pandemic in accordance with the
governor's emergency order 12 pursuant
to executive order 2020-04
as extended this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen come
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming
confirming that we are providing public
access to the meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
we are using zoom video webinar for this
remote meeting all members of the
committee and the staff state agencies
with agenda items have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously watch and or
listen to the meeting on zoom or phone
following the directions and links
provided in the house calendar
from house calendar eight to the most
current one
those house calendars can be found on
the jet
so we are providing public notice of the
necessary information for
accessing this meeting as i stated
previously
you can use a telephone and the
instructions are in the house calendar
we are providing a mechanism for the
public to alert this body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access
if you do have a problem uh email us at
lba underscore f-i-s-c-a-l
if there's a situational republican is
unable to access this meeting
we will go ahead and adjourn and
reschedule
please note that if we are to take a
vote and i don't expect any
it'll be done um by roll call
so um mr clerk are you ready to
take the role i am
okay so each member states their
presence please state whether there's
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
and that's required under our right to
representative earth a present home
alone in my home office
representative weiler i'm in kingston
and alone
i'm home in guilford my wife is in and
out of the house
okay representative wallner
i'm home um i'm alone and i'm in
my home in concord new hampshire
representative
i'm here in my dining room at my house
in hanover and i wish i had a dog with
me
[Laughter]
representative rogers i'm here in my
apartment in concord new hampshire
and my dog is sitting by my side oh
representative edwards so i'm in my home
office in
auburn new hampshire with the the door
closed
dogs and family in the other part of the
house but shouldn't come in
all division members of prison thank you
sir
uh i um i noticed we have 26
attendees uh this morning uh to the
attendees uh
what we're going to be doing today is
we're going to be listening to
dcyf we're going to be going through
their prepared presentation
in relevant portions of the budget brief
book
and will also hit their accounting lines
where we'll be asking questions
throughout the course of the
presentation
um mr ripskin
if you if you're able to see me what i'm
going to do is i'm going to wave
if anyone in the committee has questions
and if they have questions i'll try not
to interrupt you
i want you to finish your thought um and
we'll uh
we'll we'll let people ask questions
when they have them
for the public what we've been doing and
it seems to
have some benefit and it's been
successful so far
is if you have questions we will open up
the floor for you to raise your hand and
we'll bring you in and you can
you can make your point and i'll i'll
just ask you now
and i'll repeat it later but if we would
like your points to be
on specific points relative to our
deciding
how to resource a given line item
we don't we we're past the philosophy
stage because we're not a policy board
we're a resource board so um
so so those are the kinds of questions
or input that
and then i think i wanted to mention
that we've been
asked to break at noon
we have one of our key participants
needing to step out for a while so i
anticipate
a lunch break from noon to about 12 45.
and with that um mr ripple you want to
go ahead and introduce mr ripson and
we'll get going yup sure you have
karen in the meeting and also joe ribson
dcyf director
is there anybody else that i should
bring in karen and joe can you bring
over rebecca borden
okay she should be coming in and i think
you're all set
great thanks i will turn things right
over to jeff
great good morning um everybody good
morning
chair edwards and members of the
committee my name is joseph ripson i'm
the director of dcyf
i am alone in my office in concord
i'm gonna share my screen now and
representative edwards i'll let you know
whether i can see you once i share my
screen
sometimes when i share my screen i lose
the video
and i can see you so hopefully that'll
the the format you
identified will work so good morning i
can see
everyone so if they raise their hand i
can see them
excellent thank you so good morning
everybody um
thank you so much for the opportunity to
share with you um
information about what's been happening
at dcyf and
um the ways that that impacts the
decisions that you all have to make
basic identifying information around our
budget budget lines here in the
department unique identifier my contact
information is here in case you have any
follow-up questions
and then a bit about dcyf so the mission
dcyf is to partner with families and
communities to provide resources and
supports that lead to the safety and
healthy development
of children youth and the communities in
which they live
this is our current structure which um
if you're looking closely you'll notice
is actually slightly different than what
you see in the budget because we had a
we restructured things just about a
month ago and we're still in the process
of
pushing all that through on paper but
the basic structure of the division
myself is the director my general
counsel legislative liaison who many of
you know and there's a chart layer that
identifies all these individuals and
their
their time with the agency field
services which is by far the biggest
of our operations that's what people
really think of when they think of dcyf
that is all of the field staff and
district offices that do
child protection and juvenile justice
work
our chief of operations who oversees
three of our bureaus
our relatively new bureau of
professional strategic development
relatively new um bureau of evaluation
analytics and reporting
these two bureaus were split out of a
larger bureau that was called the bureau
of
organizational learning and quality
improvement
in last year's budget or last biennium's
budget there was an
additional position allocated to us for
the purpose of
bringing on another high level
administrator with expertise in
analytics
and evaluation and we just hired that
person about a month ago which is
why we've now broken this former bureau
known as bureau of organizational
learning and quality improvement
into two because we now have one person
who's focused really on
our um professional development our
training and things like that as well as
our strategic priorities and
implementation thereof and another
person who's really focused on the
evaluation
analytics and those types of things
which are key for us
as we move into a more sophisticated
service array
aligned with the federal family first
preventative services act legislation
and we'll talk more about that later
also reporting to our chief of
operations is our business information
systems those are the folks that oversee
our electronic case record and there is
uh
recommended funding in the capital
budget for updating that
antiquated electronic case record which
is 20 plus years old
work on that has begun but there's
additional resources needed to complete
that work
our bureau of community family and
program support these are the folks who
basically
are responsible for managing all of the
services and all the providers that we
work with
i'm also responsible for some of our
discrete supports to the field so things
around foster care
around adoption around permanency
supports for children and youth
our adolescent program for young adults
who are
of transition age leaving dcyf those
types of supports are handled out of
this bureau
and then the sununu youth services
program which is the state's
only secure facility for detained and
a bit of an overview and i think i
captured this really in the last slide
so i won't belabor it but really we have
three primary focuses child protection
which is um to investigate and assess
allegations of abuse or neglect
and then to work with those families
where elegant where abuse neglect is
found
to ensure safety to ensure children end
up in a forever family whether that's by
safely keeping those children at home or
reunifying those families at home after
providing services
or whether that's through adoption and
trying to have children um
find their forever families in another
home where necessary
juvenile justice which is focused as i'm
sure folks
recognize primarily on delinquency
but we also have uh services through
juvenile justice for what we call chins
in the state children in need of
services
some of those chins cases are court
involved some of them are not
and some of the data i'll share later
makes that distinction and we can go
further into that
and then sysc this new youth services
center which like i said is the state's
only
um secured setting for detained and
committed youth
mr ripson yes in my am i right to think
that
the sununu center is uh
100 in eu
code 7916 rehabilitative programs
i believe that's right karen could you
there are actually several accounting
units associated with sysc
so a little bit deeper into child
protection um this includes
uh child abuse neglect hotline right so
people call
24 7 365 to make reports of abuse
neglect that's actually relatively new
new hampshire was one of the last states
a few years ago to implement a 24 7
hotline
which it now has child abuse and neglect
assessments which are also now 24 7.
again new hampshire was one of the last
states in the union to implement a 24 7
response on child protection which we
now have
um prior to that what would typically
happen if something came in after hours
law enforcement
would remove would get involved to
potentially remove a child from their
home
and then monday morning our staff would
get involved that's really not ideal you
really want the folks who
who understand family dynamics and those
social workers making those decisions
and making those placements
in home and in community services which
are being
really redone and we'll talk more about
that a little bit later
out of home residential services
including relative care and foster care
residential care is included here and
it's largely paid for out of dcyf's
budget but management of those programs
is primarily actually through the bureau
of children's behavioral health because
those programs serve
populations that include dcyf but also
could include non-dcyf
and we can talk more about that a little
bit later reunification services so
those are services to try to help
um bring families back together when
children have had to be removed and to
keep those families stable
and then adoption and adoption services
which would include
not only um securing adoptions for young
people where we can't reunify them with
also post-adoption where families who
have already adopted are having a
challenge
the related statutes to all of this are
listed in here for
your future reference yes
so are you going to have another slide
to talk about the
hotline or or or is this
okay yeah i have some data slides ahead
which go into
some details about these different
components
so this is that slide this is the calls
to intake the hotline
as you referred to it the data that
you're seeing here is primarily coming
out of our data book
so there is the 2020 dcyf data book last
year was the first year we released a
data book we're doing this annually to
try to improve transparency and
understanding of the system
um let me explain how to read this chart
and then explain some of what we're
seeing in this chart
so the green line across the top that's
the total call volume to our hotline
you do see that we've had growth in that
number
up through state fiscal year 20 where we
did see some decline in call volume
i do think the majority of that decline
is covered related
folks will recall that in the springtime
there was a lot of news
reports about um about
seriously decreased calls to the hotline
as a result of kids not being in the
community where they typically are
school callers in particular falling off
in call volume but other providers too
we actually saw
decreases in calls for medical providers
calls from community programs calls from
social workers really almost every
category with the exception of law
enforcement
who is calling at a typical rate and
families themselves right
a grandparent may be calling on
something happening in their their grand
in their child's home or you know or you
know
one one parent calling about something
happening in another parent's home or
something like that um but other than
those two categories we did see
decreased call volume starting in march
a lot of that has picked up since i
don't have slides on that in here but we
do have slides on the web that go into
all of that
and it's something i can go into deeper
if folks want to
um the other thing you see in here which
i'm going to go into more
on the next slide is changes in the
number of what gets screened in
for an assessment that's this dark blue
the light blue what gets screened out
and then the number of additional um
information calls
so what you're seeing here part of this
reduction in what's getting screened in
is a covet impact but most of what
you're seeing there is actually a change
in practice
and what we've been doing for the past
few years trying to perfect and where i
think we're finally seeing it play out
in our data
is really improving our hotline
operations
and changing it from a system where
historically all we did when we received
a call was say yes you're screened in
and know you're screened out um to a
system where now we have a third option
which is
yes you're screened in know you're
screened out but this family could use
some additional help and you as say the
teacher we're going to help you connect
with the family resource center to get
that family the additional help that
they need
this is important for a couple reasons
one
we were conducting investigations on
families that really were never going to
end up being substantiated
so you end up putting a family through a
potentially traumatic situation of
investigation unnecessarily
and not connecting them necessarily with
the resources that they need
if we're able to do that work at intake
we're able to save
some of the um some of our bandwidth of
staff to investigate those higher risk
situations that really require our
attention
but we're also able to support
communities in supporting their own
families without getting child
protection involved which is a scary
thing for a lot of families and we don't
want to over utilize that
that lever when we don't need to so that
work has been
going on really for the past the
development work that's been going on
for a couple years but the actual
practice change has been going on for
about a year
so part of what you're seeing here in
this shift in screening and screen out
is that exact dynamic it's the dynamic
of a practice shift
um but it's also somewhat impacted by
the reduced call volume
all right i'll move on to the next slide
which goes a little bit deeper into that
so this is child protective services new
assessments
you see the assessment volume just to
orient you to the slide the green line
is oriented to the far
right axis right so the green line is
total new assessments in the year to the
far right
these bars are oriented to the left axis
that's assessment by priority response
level
i'll explain a little bit about what's
happening in both of those too so you do
see for the first time in years a
substantial drop in the number of new
assessments which is
in my view good news mostly some of this
is probably covered related
as i said on the last slide this
corresponds to what you saw on the last
slide
but some of this is because of that
the other thing that you see happening
here which which i think is reflective
of
really great improvements happening at
our intake system
is the numbers of level one level two
and level three assessments
level one means a 24-hour response that
means an emergency response level two is
a
48-hour response level three is a
72-hour response
you see the number of level ones drop
the number of level twos remain
relatively
constant and the number of level threes
drop what was happening in prior years
was because
intake was understaffed under resourced
and didn't have the
um the appropriate computer equipment
that they needed to do the appropriate
telephone lines that they needed to do
the appropriate analytical structure in
order to understand
their decision making processes all of
those things were yielding slow response
times from intake and making a decision
about whether to screen things in or out
and as a result of that things that they
would have screened into say a level two
would get screened in as a level one
because it took them a day to make the
decision
well now that we've been able to improve
operations at intake to eliminate those
challenges we're actually seeing what is
i think a more appropriate distribution
between our emergency responses and our
48-hour and 72-hour responses
um and you've seen that play out here in
the data with the number of level ones
drop
more significantly than even the number
of um of total call
i have a question for you a couple
actually uh
this these questions are related to just
getting a sense of scale
um and uh
what first question what what is the
definition of a child in this case
a child is somebody between the age of 0
do you happen to have any statistics to
show
overall what is happening to that
demographic i
i think i've seen in ways and means uh
coming out of their
graphics that shows the democrat
demographic
of uh zero to 18 is in decline in new
hampshire
is that right in our data book and i can
pull that up if you would like me to
no no it's a conversation yep i do have
in our data book
um data that does show some interesting
shifts within our demographics for
children you do see some modest decrease
the number of people under the age of 18
in recent years i think when the new
census data comes out it'll be
interesting because a lot of that's
based on assumptions
instead of an actual count for the most
recent years the other thing you see
is shift in demographics in terms of uh
racial and ethnicity
where we are seeing more um more people
of color in the state than we have
particularly children of color in this
state than we have in recent years
um and we're seeing uh you know growth
in different parts of the state
particularly in the southern part of the
state
so it sounds like your data book has a
breakdown
of region and by various demographics
who your clientele are and maybe also
the total population in that uh zero to
18 group
in that same region yes i think the data
book actually only has it by statewide i
don't think it breaks it down by
regional
but i think we might have that i think
we have that data it's just not in the
data book
okay so with all the emphasis on on on
health equity and equal access to our
systems
i'm i'm sure you're tracking that data
at that level
just to make sure that uh we know if
we're doing the right thing
yes yeah right yeah and it's one of
these areas right where
nationally we see disproportionality in
child protection and juvenile justice
um and we see it here in new hampshire
as well both again national scale and in
this state
representative walner has a question for
you
yes i um i've heard
and you know these are just individuals
who
bring forth a specific case
but i've heard that there have been
increases in the number of children
who have been referred to dcyf
because they've not been attending
school and i'm wondering if
if you have seen an increase in um
referrals around children not coming not
attending school
and if so what kinds of resources
or um things can we do for those
families i mean i think there's probably
a
wide variety of reasons why children
haven't attended school during covid
i wondered if you could say something
about that absolutely thank you for the
question
yes that is correct i actually have
another entire presentation
on that topic that i could share with
folks if they're interested but we um
we did know this starting in the fall
it's interesting we did not notice this
at all in the spring when schools first
closed but starting in the fall
really dramatic increases both on
juvenile justice and child protection
around in child protection what's called
educational neglect
um referrals in the juvenile justice
what we call truancy referrals
um really two sides of the same coin
typically educational neglect
involves younger children truancy
involves older children although
that you know either population could
end up in either bucket depending on the
circumstances
we saw really really dramatic growth in
both
starting in october
we did a little bit of a qualitative
analysis based on that and pulled
together some focus groups of the staff
who were handling these cases to try to
understand what the dynamics were there
and what we were really hearing back was
that um
overwhelmingly these were not situations
where kids were really being abused or
neglected
um you know prevented from accessing
education because of any parental
um problems but rather families who were
just really stressed with trying to
balance the
requirements of um you know being
parents
working remotely or not one of the cases
that was brought forward was a woman who
was
a waitress and had to bring her
six-year-old to the diner every day to
do the remote school and
you know that's not a parent who's
abusing or neglecting their kids that
that's a parent who's really a hero
trying to figure out a really tough
situation
um so some of the other things that we
heard were some challenges with
technology
um that wasn't overwhelming it was
really the balancing of priorities for
parents
we did hear some challenges around
certain schools having some pretty
draconian policies around what counts as
absent or not
um for example one district that would
if a student didn't want to turn their
camera on they would count them as
absent for the day
i might i understand why the school
would want the camera on at the same
time that in that instance the student
was really ashamed of
their household conditions and just was
not going to be convinced to turn on
that camera
um in front of their peers which i can
understand and that's not a student who
i think needs to be punished for that
right that's a
that's a different type of situation to
manage so
um you know we've seen a lot but i think
at the end of the day it really comes
down to families
struggling with these different um
challenges
i do think you know given the huge
rise that we've seen in this remote
learning environment
i do think the remote and hybrid
learning is is probably the driving
factor in this we did give some advice
to the school
districts we had a uh forum boe helped
us pull together the school districts
where we saw this shift occurring most
frequently
two weeks ago um and we hosted a forum
for those school districts where we
shared all this data shared these
stories and gave them some advice
a lot of that advice was around just
really making sure they're utilizing
their guidance counselors and social
workers to troubleshoot before they're
making referrals to us
because as i said before when we go out
that can be a scary experience and while
we
i think are pretty good at problem
solving with families it would be nice
to
have these families and others be able
to solve these problems directly
one of the other pieces of advice we
gave was contacting their local family
resource centers many of them were
willing to assist
with families in these positions we
shared again with them something that we
developed last spring and updated in
december called the child and family
well-being guide that was a tool that we
created at the start of covid
that on the front of it basically
acknowledged that all families were
struggling now
that and provided a host of questions
that people could ask to kind of talk to
families about what their needs are and
then on the back give them a list of
resources that they can connect those
families to
with the idea being that we wanted our
teachers but not just our teachers our
communities as a whole
to be able to connect with families and
help families meet their needs
i'm hoping that that would prevent some
of the deeper end stuff that we see when
families are neglected for a long period
of time
the last recommendation on that sheet
was though that that i would hope
schools would try to find ways to get
those kids in school
right even if they weren't ready to open
up entirely
that kids that are that they're so
worried about that they're referring for
truancy
and and educational neglect based on
absenteeism
it's a relatively small population
compared to the entire school population
and probably is a population that they
need to think about prioritizing as an
at-risk population to be in person
and i you know i think largely the
districts who were present were
receptive to all of those ideas and
i would say um all of them seemed like
they were really
working hard to try to problem solve
these things i didn't get the sense from
anybody that they were indifferent to
thank you i wondered if i could have
just one follow-up
can you um give me just a ballpark
figure of how many
um calls you did have about educational
um neglect um if the chair wouldn't mind
if i pull down this presentation and
pull up another one i can give you the
exact figure
i i'll cut my head i don't remember it
can you can you wait for that uh
representative
oh yes anytime that's fine thank you
okay i i think i think we're clear
um i one just to foreshadow
my questions when we get to the
spreadsheets
it looks like with your workload going
down
general funds are going up quite a lot
in the governor's budget
but it looks like most of that's
offsetting declines in
federal budget so um so
it'll be after lunch before we talk
about that and i just didn't want to
forget
that i wanted to have that conversation
with you
yeah and one other thing i would add on
that point when we get to it is that
the system still isn't right size right
the system was
way under um under resourced a few years
ago
and the right resources were put in
place to help us build that out but as
you'll see as we go further into this
you know hiring retention has been a
challenge and we still have more work to
do
and one of the ways we measure that and
it's also in here is through looking at
case loads of staff
so even though there are fewer
assessments today than there were then
um i don't think we're in a position
where we have um
where we have you know too many staff to
meet the demand and
you can see that when we get into
actually this chart right here
the uh the assessment case loads
so national standards around the the
case load that a caseworker should have
in a child and protection in a child
protection work
when they're doing assessments or
investigations is 12.
and that is that is a national standard
it is not you this has not been tested
specifically for new hampshire
a couple years ago when this
conversation started happening we didn't
talk about having a workload study done
to to develop a specific one for new
hampshire
ultimately at that point the
in that piece of legislation that was
stripped out and not funded so we didn't
do that
with the recognition in that committee
hearing that people thought the national
standard of 12
sounded like an appropriate caseload and
i'm i am comfortable with that but i
would say that
in new hampshire you know we expect our
case workers to do things that we didn't
that we don't in other jurisdictions
you know and for example in new jersey
where i came from our caseworkers didn't
have to do much work on
um complaints and pleadings because
there were paralegals employed to do all
that work we're here
um our caseworkers have to do a lot of
have to carry a lot of that work because
we don't have those uh paralegals in
place
but at any rate what i think you're
saying is that
uh the the definition of what's in a
case
to create case loads it varies by state
and that in that anecdotally you just
said
our cases are heavier because we're
asking them to do more work
than the states you're familiar with
that's correct
exactly right okay and so you probably
thought
about how how our definition of a case
really does compare nationally so that
we're not just you know naively looking
at the number
12 but we're actually understanding what
that means
yes yeah and i and as i said we did um
when we first started having this
conversation about three years ago when
i
moved to new hampshire and took on this
job that was one of the things that we
sought to do
but ultimately we decided not to not to
invest in that type of workload study
all right all right thank you i don't
know if you want to take that before i
move oh
representative weiler has his hand up
thank you mr chairman director
this is a huge reduction in case laws
will we see further on what this has
accomplished will there be
quote more cases closed more cases dealt
with will there be an improvement in the
overall
health of our children yes this
reduction is that going to be something
we see
yes yes for all the above um thank you
thank you
the the case loads um you know really
in january 2016 at being over 90 is
something that is
absolutely unheard of nationally right
with the target being 12 to have
somebody carrying 90 cases on average
around the state is
unfathomable what you really want to get
to with the caseload of 12 or whatever
that lower number is
is the opportunity for our assessment
workers for investigation workers to be
able to do more than simply
say yes abuse occurred or no it didn't
but to actually start to problem solve
with the family
identify what their needs are meet their
needs and actually within the context of
these educational neglect cases that
that representative wallner just raised
um i'm getting great feedback from folks
about what they're seeing there
those are those are complex cases not
because they're abuse or neglect
but because the social workers have to
do a lot of work to problem solve and
connect with different
different folks in the community to wrap
around that family to make sure that
that issue gets resolved
but ideal child protection practice
allows for that
allows for caseworkers to do that and if
they have a case load of 12 they can do
that
if they have a caseload of 40 which is
where we've been for most of my time
here
it's impossible to do that so you do see
this rapid reduction
um certainly the reduced call volume
from covert was part of this
but part of this is also that change
that we talked about at intake part of
this is the new positions that we've
that we received in the last biennium
that we've hired that we've trained
it takes a number of months to train
someone once they're hired before they
carry a case of this delay
but you do see this decrease really
starting you know back here
in 2019 um in the fall of 2019 right
after those first
people were hired in july of 2019 um
and then that decrease really continuing
to sustain and really speed up through
the springtime as folks were hired
and now really has been sustained over
the past couple months
i do expect it's going to continue to
improve i actually think
that um if we maintain the current the
current staffing positions that
eventually we will get to that target of
we've got gotten to the point now where
the reductions are harder to come by
in case load and when i say that that's
because
when we were up here there was this huge
backlog right staff were triaging
their who were they going to pay
attention to on a given day and then
things that were less risky by
definition were kind of being back
burned
and weren't closing so a lot of this big
number here is because of things that
are left open that really could have
closed if people had the bandwidth to
close them
we've now gotten through that problem
which is where we are today
this kind of status this kind of a
17-ish
number um and really pushing further
down is going to require us to get the
rest of these positions
filled trained and carrying cases um
it's not going to be as simple as kind
of cleaning up the backlog which is what
a lot of this
representative waller so
um i mean i like that we
the caseload is declining um we seem to
be accomplishing what we set out to do
but what bothers me is it it it's low
during
covid and you're anticipating that
when children go back to school and
they're out more into the community
and um that those caseloads
will go back up does the budget account
for higher case loads but
a 12 case load load for a worker
yeah so when we calculated the number of
staff that we needed to
to do both child protection assessments
which this is and then the next
thing we're going to talk about is child
protection family services
that was based on data um at the start
of the last biennium
which was a lot higher than what we
actually see right now during covet in
which
given the changes in practice that
intake i would expect
to be able to absorb kind of any
post-covet bump that we see i'm actually
not sure that we're going to see a big
post-covet bump
because we've seen our call volume
really resumed to pretty close to
typical levels in the past few months
now the kids are even though they're not
meeting in person they are back in
school a little bit more they're
interacting with communities a little
bit more
so we've seen our call volume get pretty
close to normal even though not entirely
there in the past couple months
so i do think that the that the
positions that are
identified in the budget will allow us
to get to the caseload standards of 12
and 10 for family service that we're
going to talk about next
there were some that were unfunded in
the in the initial budget that i do
think are going to be necessary for us
to achieve that goal
i also believe that the governor sent a
letter yesterday within which he
articulated uh support for funding those
positions
um going forward even though they
weren't in the original
proposal so you know i'm hopeful that we
see that resolved through the budget
process
and i do believe that if all those
positions are funded and if we just keep
the hard work of trying to hire and
train and keep people
we will have the resources we need to
get there
um just a follow-up um
is that the 22 positions um are those 2
is it 22 positions that are unfunded
that's correct
so all right are you anticipating
good morning mr ribson um are you
anticipating
much change after we get past this comet
i mean i think
the issue is probably that the cases are
maybe more complicated
um but are you anticipating more of a
flat line
for um like the end of the summer
or the other comment i guess i would
make is
one of the issues we had when we first
came into this with the last budget
was that we you were having trouble with
retention of staff
because everyone was just so overwhelmed
has that
gotten better and are you more able to
keep the staff you have
thanks thank you yes um
so i do i think what's what's a little
unique about new hampshire compared to
some of the other jurisdictions
and this last chart kind of shows that i
have other data that shows it better
but compared to other jurisdictions our
our number of calls coming to the
hotline and the number of new
assessments
we're on a huge upward swing prior to
covid not based on anything related to
covid
but based on what you see in many
jurisdictions when you get into a point
um where you have a lot of a lot of
attention
around high profile fatalities and a lot
of risk-averse behavior
which leads to a lot of assessments and
sometimes unnecessary assessments which
is why we
made that shifted intake that i spoke
about earlier
so what i would anticipate is i
certainly would not anticipate a post
proven state getting any higher than our
say state fiscal year 2019 which was a
record-setting year historically for us
in terms of new assessments and when we
when we created the number of positions
that we needed
in the last biennium that's the data we
were looking at so i do think
again that the current number of
positions within the within the budget
assuming the funding of those 22
um is appropriate and adequate to get us
to the caseload standards that we all
want
the other issue that you touch on i'm
representative norgren and i'll talk
about a little bit more later
around turnover we have seen improvement
there's data in the data book that does
show
um you know the turnover rate um
shifting from about 20
to about 17 in terms of people leaving
the agency
that's still not a number i'm satisfied
with the
healthy organization of our size you
anticipate something like a 10
turnover rate i would anticipate seeing
that in the coming years i think the
driving factors
for turnover are a few um one of them is
um is case loads and people not feeling
that they can be successful in their
work
um with caseloads going down i think
there's some more satisfaction around
that i think the other component of that
that we're actively working on is
redesigning our services for families
that's an integral component to make
sure that folks can be successful in
their work which is why they stay
right people who come into this work do
it because they want to help families
and if they don't feel successful it's
just too hard to bear
day in and day out when we have those
services that we're redesigning totally
in place
i think people are going to feel even
better satisfaction from the job the
other big thing is what we kind of call
our
our safety culture work that we're
actively engaged in and that's around
creating an environment where folks feel
safe and i don't just mean physical
safety which is one component of it but
i need psychological safety
and support one big component that was
funded in the last biennium which has
been
amazing was the hiring of a clinical
person whose job it is to look for the
secondary trauma needs of staff and
support staff
around those issues right our staff see
a lot of really scary horrible things
that can really you know haunt the
person on any normal person
and it's hard for them to stick it out
without that type of support so
that has been invaluable i'm really
grateful that was provided in the last
biennium
it's it's funded in the next biennium in
the proposed budget i
you know i i hope that it remains
through the legislative process
it's been um it's been fabulous the
other piece of that is really working
around the culture to create what's kind
of called psychological safety or an
environment where people can speak
freely and openly about what their needs
are what their fears are what their
risks are
not just about themselves and their work
but about the families that they work
with
um and that's something that when you
have a system like ours was a few years
ago where it's
constantly under scrutiny people get
very risk averse and get afraid to talk
because they're afraid they're gonna get
in trouble
and changing that dynamic is is really
imperative
not just to satisfaction but also to
making sure we get the right information
to make the best
decisions for kids and families so we've
been actively working in that space as
well
the new clinical person is a big part of
that team we have another role called a
safety culture specialist who's part of
that team
and they're part of a national
collaborative actually called the
partnership on child safety which
includes
jurisdictions from across the country
that really are focused on these issues
and how do you make sure that you
support your workforce appropriately
to enable healthy decision making and
good decision making for families
so all that's to say is i do think it's
going to get better but it has
but we're not there yet so this is just
a yes or no question and maybe a
conversation
offline someday but you have a clinical
psychologist who's providing
you know sort of front line support to
the employees
it's it sounds like that's very much of
a eap
function and are you convinced
that you need that to augment the
state's
existing eap program
i am convinced that it's absolutely
necessary yeah
sounds a little redundant but you're
able to justify the redundancy
yeah i think it's i i think that there's
a unique
set of challenges that our staff face
that are discrete
from what most folks face now is it
possible to structure some of that
within
within the eap that eap is it's
currently structured
and currently resource doesn't have the
bandwidth to meet that need for us where
this individual does
okay so as the case moves on so as you
move beyond the assessment phase a
number of situations
will be found where abuser neglect has
occurred or where children and families
are deemed to be at very high risk
and a higher the next level will open up
a family service case is what we call
that
overwhelmingly these are cases that go
to court so where you saw the big
numbers on the prior slide about
assessments um that's you know obviously
a much bigger number because
few of those cases will reach this point
where they actually go to court
and where there's an open ongoing case
the numbers that you see here on the
green line
um are the total number of family
service cases in the given year you do
see the growth
and then kind of the the stability over
the past
fiscal year um what you also see here is
the number of children
served right there are more children in
a case than one typically
right so you'll have the number of cases
might be
1500 but the number of children served
you know is close to 3 000
because you often have two or more
children in a case
so the other thing that this slide shows
in addition to the number of family
service cases
is the number of children who are being
served in those cases the number of
children who are being served in out of
home care
the number of children being served in
in-home care and this has been a
priority for us in the past few years i
think new hampshire had a practice
of over-relying on family separation
over relying on removing children from
homes
where it wasn't necessary to provide
supports and strength
to those supports for those families to
strengthen them and keep those kids safe
in their own homes
so i'm happy to see the number of
in-home um
cases you know higher than it was in
those prior years
and the number of kids who were out of
home care you know starting to tick down
after you know growth year after year
after year
so what do you think um your your best
case scenario is for this distribution
of kids staying in their homes
[Music]
you know um i would like to see these
numbers flipped
right i'd like to see more in home than
out of home um
depending a lot of this depends on how
you count it right so
the way that we counted this work in new
jersey we'd say 85 percent of our kids
are at home
but that would be misleading because it
was also counting things like kids who
were engaged in assessments
who were being worked in their own homes
or kids being engaged in something like
what we would call community-based
voluntary services here that i can talk
a little bit more about later
so i don't think we'll get to something
like that the way that we count this
distribution in new hampshire
um but i do think we can get to a point
where we see these two bars flipped and
that's what i would hope to see in the
coming years
as our new services come on the line to
better support kids at home
so this is the family service case loads
our goal here is 10 the reason why the
goal here is 10 rather than 12 as it is
for assessment is that
these are family service cases are
almost always in court
these are the families that we have
identified are at high risk
kids are either removed from home or
there's really really intensive work
happening with those families in their
own homes
and just frankly the work is heavier on
the family service caseload
on an individual case than it would be
on an assessment case load
so the target here is 10. you do see
that number you know as the number of
kids in out of home care grew really was
kind of
popping around close to 20 and still
today is kind of bouncing around in this
you know 13-14 range
part of the reason why you've seen less
decline here than you see on the other
chart is as i said before that other
chart
has had a lot of noise in it from
overdue things and things that were just
kind of on the back burner where
none of this work can be back burner
because by definition all of these
families are at high risk aren't deeply
involved into the system
so i think there's i do think that
the as we continue to hire we do have
the right staff load the right staffing
to get down to
the target of 10 um but we still see
that this is you know something that we
have to keep working at to get down to
that number
the red line on above is just the number
of children
your department is competent as in
everyone might be
you can't control the number of
cases that go to the course because
that's driven by
family dysfunction correct
so so you're reacting to something you
can't control i would think but it made
it you made it sound like
you can positively influence a reduction
in that
number yes i don't get that
yes but i think it is true that we can
positively influence a reduction in that
number
and that is through being able to
provide more preventative services up
front which we'll talk a little bit
about later
but if we're able to do things like the
things that are currently underway for
example
the system of care work in children's
behavioral health
the um the work that's expanding through
family resource centers and family
and the facilitating organization the
work that's expanding through public
health and community collaboration
grants all of those things and and that
work that we're doing at intake to try
to direct families who are
lower risk to a community resource
before they become high risk
all of those things will drive these
numbers down over time and i've
experienced that through my work in new
jersey for the decade prior to coming
here
but as we um as we built out those
supports for families
the number of kids going into out of
home care plummeted
from thousands a year to from you know
over 10 000 a year to i think around 4
000 a year today
so i do think that you actually can
positively impact these challenges
around family dysfunction but to do so
you really need to think um much more
proactively
than the way a child protection system
is typically designed right child
protection is typically designed to be
reactive
and you really need to work with our
partners to be more proactive in order
so are you are you basing
that projection on your anecdotal
experience
or do you think there's peer-reviewed
research
to indicate that systems of care in this
area
can be accountable for
a reduction in cases in in court
i'm not trying to get the difference
between good
theory good experience and good data
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure what the
where what the research is specifically
on it what i can tell you
is i worked in a system that built all
of these things around the time that i
started there 15 years ago
and through the period of building all
those things we saw a rapid
and sustained and still happening today
decline of children entering out of home
care
um and when i say rapid and sustained i
don't just mean
you know a 10 reduction i mean from 12
kids um to about 4
500 kids today in new jersey and the
the change that happened was the
investments in the system of care
and the investments and other
preventative supports in new jersey we
call them family success centers here we
call them family resource centers
but those were really the two main
things that we did to drive these
numbers down
in addition to in addition to the work
around improving the services that are
offered within
the child protection agency itself that
we're currently engaged in
so this is the number this is just a
different way to look at that same data
the number of children point in time the
last chart showed you kind of
cumulatively over the year but at point
in time so you can imagine on any given
day
this is what you see um you know this
can be it's helpful
to think about it's also a little bit
misleading because on one given day a
number could be a little bit off this is
just looking on the first day of the
reporting period
but it does give you a sense of kind of
on any given day you would expect
you know about a thousand a thousand
seventy kids who are out of home care
and child protection
and about 500 or so kids who are in
in-home care and child protection
we do see that rapid growth that
occurred in out-of-home care that i
talked about that really coincides with
um what i think was was a lot of risk
aversion
being driven by the attention through
those high profile fatalities
and then us finally being able to come
over that hump and starting to stabilize
i'm not satisfied with this number this
1067 i think this can be a lot lower
than it is
i think what's going to help us get a
lot lower what it is is the work that
we're currently engaged in
and redesigning the services that we
provide to families um
who are in the deep end of the system we
can talk more about that a little bit
so i have a quick anecdote to share with
you and i
i'm just trying to figure out if this
would uh if this kind of thing
affects your data um
a friend of mine left his five-year-old
son in the car for a few minutes
he was sure assured of the guy the kid's
safety
ran in ran out he says he was away from
the car for five minutes
somebody uh called the police department
the police department went to his house
and and ask him some questions
so so based on that scenario
do you open a case for that it would be
incredibly unlikely that if that's the
only factor that we
definitely wouldn't open a case right a
family service case
maybe an investigation could be open
based on you know based on that
information
but the idea that that would then if
those are the only factors
that that would move beyond the
investigatory phase into a case
yeah absolutely not that doesn't reach
that threshold
okay so mirror investigation doesn't
constitute a case
that's right yeah and if you look at the
distinction between right the numbers on
this
page again right where you're talking
about you know 1500 cases a year
compared to the assessments where we're
talking about
10 000 in the last year right that's the
gap there that's what we're talking
about
and i think there was another question
uh there is
uh representative weiler i was a little
confused between
this chart on page 12 and then later on
the chart
18. uh look very similar but
showing different numbers i think 18 is
referring to juvenile justice so when we
get into that
that place so these are more serious
cases
so this is talking about child
protection cases this is where a child
is
potentially removed from their home
because the parent
because there's some concern about the
parent and the safety in the home
juvenile justice cases are typically
related to delinquency and or chins
which is you know child being a danger
or risk
i don't see any other questions okay
so this is getting a little bit into the
questions that folks were asking around
hiring retention and things like that um
basically what you're seeing in this
chart is the net change in cpsw
positions in a given month
um what we're doing here just so you
understand is looking at this data in
the next chart right so the
this column the new higher column that's
how many new new people were hired
during that
that month or that year how many people
left the agency during that year or that
month
and how many promotions and the reason
we include the promotions is because
that does have an impact on the number
of people providing services
the positions that were added in the
last biennium which we needed in order
to
have more supervisors to supervise these
staff
those were typically hired from within
right so that then creates a vacancy of
the front line position
that that needs to be filled but what
this does show
is that i think we are making progress
um
every single month and getting closer to
our goal of having uh
full staffing we still do have you know
last year was almost
100 new hires which is you know a
record-breaking year for us i
i think i'm pretty proud of the work
that was done to hire
almost 100 new people last year we had
40 people who left the agency outright
and 15 who were promoted to other spots
so your net there would be
you know a 55 out of 97. so you only
even though you hired 97 people your net
gain was only you know 30 whatever that
turns into when you do the math
um but all that's to say is i
i do think we are continuing to make
progress and that we will be able to
continue to fill all the positions
so i look at this and i have about two
or three questions for you
they're they're all kind of related so
so to what extent
are is your age force graying out and
getting really close to retirement which
would then trigger
yet more need to hire and to what extent
is um the the skill set that you're
looking to hire
actually available in new hampshire
already because we found in some other
areas in healthcare
uh we need higher people that just don't
exist
so so yeah yeah i think two things i
think the child protection workforce is
actually relatively
young at this point because there's been
so much turnover and so much new hiring
um our real challenge around the child
protection workforce is having enough
seasoned staff to be mentors
at this point the juvenile justice
workforce is a different dynamic
they're a much more seasoned workforce
than our child protection workforce
the other question around having the
right folks in the state to hire i do
think that's a challenge
i think not only are we looking to hire
folks with social work
either social workers or with skills
comparable to social workers
but there are a lot of other folks who
are looking for those same type of skill
sets right now
so i think there is some scarcity in
terms of folks
i would say though with the fact that
we've been able to hire 97 in the last
year and
probably received a thousand
applications um
that that i think we'll get there it's
just gonna keep taking us time
um yeah yeah that's it
so to what extent um is are you having
success or are you having challenges
related to
hiring a workforce that reflects the
community they're serving
i you know i think that is a challenge
um
you know i don't have i don't have the
demographic data on our workforce but
our workforce
probably particularly in certain parts
of the state where we have
uh greater latinx populations and
greater african-american populations
i don't think our workforce is
particularly reflective of of those
demographics
that's something that i'd like to like
to see changed
um i think it's really critical
in all of these roles to hire people
from their home communities though
um and that also includes you know other
than racial and ethnic
um but you know having folks from the
north country working in the north
country makes a difference right
it's uh having people who are reflective
of their community and community
values i think really helps in that
community relation aspect of the work
so representative walner has a question
i just i just wondered
what is your vacancy rate at this time
and how many vacancies
do you have i think at this moment there
are
30 i i'd have to double check it
somewhere in the high 30s i believe of
vacant cpsw positions
okay and just to do a time check we've
been talking for
about an hour uh you're probably behind
where you thought you'd be at this point
but um so if so just
mentally if you could plan on on
shutting down for
in about 25 minutes so that we can take
a graceful break
uh for lunch absolutely all right
all right so now we're moving out of
child protection and juvenile justice
assuming no other
representative your hand is still up do
you have a follow-up
no i'm sorry i just need to lower it
okay go ahead i'm sorry
great so moving into juvenile justice
juvenile justice
works um around delinquency right so
children commit acts
um are found to have committed acts that
would be
children in need of services chins they
can be both voluntary and involuntary
the distinction here an involuntary
chin's case typically involves
always involves court if the chin's case
is going to require a placement under
new hampshire statute it must involve
court
and there are standards that have to be
met to um to qualify for what's called
an involuntary chance largely around
um the child's behaviors you know being
dangerous
to themselves to others to their
families voluntary chins cases are often
what we see in say a truancy matter so
we talked earlier about the truancy
cases that are coming in
the way that that actually often plays
out is rather than a court case
involving truancy
is we receive a call from a school
saying this young person is
truant we need to get services in place
to try to get them reengaged
in their community and in their school
and we open up what's called a voluntary
chins case to work with that family
without taking them to court
sometimes truancy cases do end up in
court but the vast majority of them end
up in this voluntary chin space
in home and in community services
includes you know some youth and
residential care often times when
the vast majority of times if the youth
in juvenile justice ends up in out of
home care
they're going to a residential program
rather than a foster home
support for permanency of youth that's
really around if kids do get placed out
of home trying to make sure that they
can return to their home communities or
for some reason
they can't return to their parents that
we work with other family members that
they can return to
representative has a question yes
thank you um do you keep statistics
on the number of children who show up in
the juvenile justice
system who were at one point
or another in the child protection
system
i don't have that handy but we but we
but we can pull that data and there is
quite a bit of a crossover population
okay i i would at some point like to see
that
not not now but that would be
interesting to see
how many children have been involved who
are moving from one system to the other
yep and it sometimes moves either way
you know something yes
from one to the other and you know but
so here's juvenile justice services open
cases by state fiscal year
you do see some decline in new juvenile
justice cases over the past couple years
i do think state fiscal year 20
is anomalous because there was a huge
drop in juvenile justice cases when
schools closed in march
um more even more pronounced than we saw
on the child protection side
and i think that just speaks to an awful
lot of the juvenile justice delinquency
concerns really stem
and originate out of issues happening
within schools
um but we have seen some decline in the
number of uh
of um juvenile justice cases across the
board over the past couple years
you do see here the dark blue you've
served in placement out of their homes
typically in residential programming and
you've served in their homes
i am glad to see that the number of
youth served in their homes
is a lot higher than the number of youth
served out of their homes and
actually if you look at the placement
numbers um some pretty good progress in
the past couple years of trying to serve
more kids in their own homes rather than
serving them within
a residential placement
this is just breaking down that data by
the case types
um so we talked about delinquency right
that's child commits an act that um
uh you know would would be considered a
criminal act whether in adult
chins cases which are those cases that i
was talking about child
need of services the green are the
chance pieces with court involvement
so they often do incorporate some kind
of out of home
residential placement chins without
court which are those voluntary chins
that i was talking about
and you do see the number of delinquency
cases dropping you do see your chins
kind of you know growing or staying
steady um during this period
again i think state fiscal year 20 is
anomalous and hard to really look at as
a
as part of a trend because so much of
that was impacted by the uh
by the onset of covid um but even
through that you do see that the
court chins cases uh maintained and
actually have had some slight growth
over the past few
so these are juvenile justice case loads
you know we're looking for about 15 here
there's i don't put a target on this one
because i
i don't know of a good national standard
for this so i just have
i haven't identified the target but what
we try to work towards is a case load of
15.
and you do see you know largely in jj
they've been able to maintain around
that number you just see it a little bit
lower
over the past uh you know year or so
you know in this coding period where the
this is a the chart that um that
representative weiler was was raising
talking about youth juvenile justice
services youth and open cases so on
juvenile justice
the number of youth point in time so at
the start of the reporting period so
january 1st with an in-home juvenile
justice case we actually see some growth
there
and really what's driving that growth is
those truancy cases that we were talking
about
the voluntary shins truancy cases which
you don't see in this chart yet
because this is state fiscal year data
this only goes through july
but you do see it in here where we went
through january
um and you do see the the steady decline
of use of residential care right 116 jj
kids you know
and out of home care which is which is
good news that might be overstated as a
trend a little bit right now because
there are also restrictions through the
covet on getting children who
need higher levels of care into those
programs
so some of that might be a little
exaggerated in the data we'd have to see
you know where that plays out as as we
and then this is you know something that
i'm really excited about i'm hopeful
we're able to move forward with this
some juvenile justice transformation
work there is a senate bill which hasn't
yet had a hearing
senate bill 94 i put the plus there
because there's some other things that
aren't related to that bill
involved in this work but some folks
might recall that
you know maybe six months prior to
clover that seems to be the way that we
identify the world now
a group of us were awarded an
opportunity to go down to georgetown
university
work with national experts around
juvenile justice and
think about how do we how do we
re-envision our juvenile justice system
to better meet the needs of youth the
folks who went
on that trip it was a multi-disciplinary
group they're all identified here
did include somebody from the public
defender's office included our child
advocate
some the diversion coordinator for the
state judge ashley from the
circuit courts as well as a prosecutor
from manchester
and through that work we've really
identified two big broad goals that
we're trying to achieve in the coming
years
senate bill 14 helps with one of those
big goals number one
is offering the opportunity to have law
enforcement
refer youth to us for an assessment
that's not going to be like a
big child protection assessment but
rather an assessment of the youth's
needs
and then being able to allow us to
use that opportunity to connect those
youth with the appropriate services in
the community before
the petition ever has to be filed the
idea being that if we divert kids at
that point catch them earlier
at that point we can divert them from
the formal court systems drive down the
number of formal court cases that are
involved
and get kids the help they need sooner
which in the long run
should both reduce the number of
delinquency cases but also should reduce
the utilization of more intensive
services like residential programming
the other big piece of this is to look
at the rules of probation they haven't
really been updated in about 20 years
this is not a statutory thing so that's
where i put the plus up there it has to
be
94 plus that's not really a legislative
thing but rather it's a court rule
and looking at those rules in a way that
we can think about how do we get from a
place where we have a
cookie cutter approach which we
currently do in our probation rules that
every youth follows the same 20 rules
to where we actually look at the needs
of youth and identify what those needs
are and tailor the rules to what the
focus of their case plan is
i'm really excited about this we do not
anticipate needing additional staff for
this
what we're kind of counting on is the
idea that if we
um are able to slowly implement which
senate bill 14
is designed to do this process we can
get some staff doing these assessments
on the front end
reducing the back-end delinquency
caseload and basically use the existing
workforce just in a different way to
help reduce these case loads over time
so that's something i'm really excited
about i wanted to share here
can i throw a thought at you sure what
what would
what would be nice for future budgeting
drills
is to be able to um describe
uh what what the manpower and support
structure would look like to create this
this new way of working with our
juvenile cases
and be able to articulate you know what
the workload metrics are
that drive the manpower analysis
and then how you're going to measure
effectiveness and quality
[Music]
and and it's probably way early for you
to have any of that but
but i think any time we introduce a new
program like this
we it you know we we all want it to be a
a huge success and want to buy into the
the vision but i but we also need to
come back and just do the math
yep understood yeah we are still in the
development phase on this
so now we're moving into sysc and i
don't know whether you want me to
continue you want to you wanted to go
till noon so i can go through this now
how many slides well this is a huge
topic
um so but breaking before noon i don't
think helps the person that needed to
leave at noon so
um let's go ahead and
get started sure so sununu youth
services center
the last area that um was planning on
talking about around dcyf
services syc include you know creation
of treatment plans clinical and
psychiatric assessments educational and
vocational planning and services
medical dental nutritional services
family engagement
safety community reentry work
recreational and experiential
opportunities for youth
and then reunification and permanency
planning for use essentially
sysc is as i said before the only
facility in the state uh for detained
and committed youth
and um the services that have to go into
that are
are are pretty robust and comprehensive
so mr ribson i'm gonna i'm gonna cheat a
little bit
and kind of just tell you you and i were
trying to talk before
the session really got busy and i'll
just
i'll just frame frame this now
to kind of give you a sense of where i
think a few of us are at
and and that is that the sununu center
was was built in a time with a different
vision
built with a different capacity and
role in mind and since then
the population has dwindled
to small numbers 10 12 maybe 15 i don't
know small numbers
but because of the overhead associated
with having to provide
services in a broad way
it's become unbearably expensive on a
per
resident basis and and
and i and i hate to just jump to the
kind of almost the conclusion
but but where i think we would probably
get the most
bang for our buck and talking to you is
if you just spoke uh more directly to
the idea
of what you think needs to happen to
fundamentally transform
the role and purpose of the sununu
center and how that's reflected
in your in the governor's budget request
and maybe those are two different things
maybe the governor's budget request
didn't anticipate
radical transformation but but
that would just be great to have i think
that conversation here
instead of maybe the kind of the
prepared this is the way things are
story sure sure maybe i can give
just a little bit of a view at the at
some of the data because i think it
informs that conversation but i think
that's the right conversation to have
um so as you were saying right this data
shows what the census of the facility is
for the past few years and what we've
seen
the dark line at the bottom is the
average daily
population for that state fiscal year
last state fiscal year the average daily
population was 16.9
i haven't checked today yesterday we
have 13 youth in the facility but
there's some data that'll shoot that
i'll show you in a minute that
those numbers change pretty drastically
on a daily basis
um this also shows the number of total
youth committed youth you do see
78 total youth throughout that period
but 108 commit
commitments or admissions rather which
speaks to kind of the
the revolving door that we unfortunately
do see at sysc sometimes of youth
being discharged and then coming right
this is the daily census across that
period and the reason i wanted to share
this is that
the average daily census can be a little
bit misleading
sometimes i see folks cherry pick a
certain date and say oh there were six
there's only eight kids there
those numbers do change pretty
dramatically um
certainly nowhere near the 144 that was
built for
but you know last july we were up into
the high 20s
i think we've kind of stabilized into
what typically is more in this 15 or
lower range
you do have dates that it gets down even
lower but then it can very rapidly jump
back up which all present some
challenges around trying to
operationalize and staff now getting to
your
a couple other points i just want to
make sorry the um
one of the things that we've seen with
the ships at sysc is kind of what i
would call an
increase in acuity of the youth that
were there so i think the changes that
were made around admissions to sysc has
led to far
fewer youth but the youth that get there
are youth that have um you know more
challenges
you can see that play out in some of
this right the average number of
petitions
that's delinquency petitions for a youth
in state fiscal year 16 was
about you know a little less than 10.
today it's a little closer to 15
average petitions per youth um
on the committed population the detained
population relatively
you know stable we did see some growth
there from from about eight to about 11
not quite as drastic as you see in the
um sorry one too far so i think to get
to
uh the points that you're making though
there's a couple things i think
reducing the census that sysc hasn't
done as much to reduce the cost of the
facility that people would have thought
that it would
and there's a couple reasons for that
and it's not
i don't think as much based on the
overhead of the facility
that is part of the contributing factor
it's much more based on the needs of
programming for that facility
when we made these changes of the number
of youth essentially we've reduced the
economies of scale
to such a point that that the individual
youth there still require
really high levels of care even though
there are fewer of them
um and it gets really complex um
and some of this it's unfortunate we're
having this meeting before the i think
the next joint fiscal meeting the
legislative budget assistant is putting
out
an audit of syse which starts to talk
through some of this stuff
um from somebody other than myself um
so it'd be helpful for you all to have
that but in a few weeks you will
um but part of what we see there that's
really challenging
is a lot of the youth um have different
programming needs and have to be kind of
set
on separate units and things like that
that requires additional staffing
so for example if we have a female in
the facility which we often do
often it's just one sometimes it's two
or three that
female requires a separate unit that
unit requires separate staff
we generally maintain two male units
um we really can't get less than two
male units regardless of how many youth
are in the building because it's very
common
that the males in the facility have a
court order that they have to be kept
separately because they either have some
challenges outside with each other you
know um you know what what some folks
might say is gang involvement viable
gang involvement or some other type of
maybe they were involved in a common
um act of delinquency and the
prosecutors in the court order that
they'd be kept separate
while they're within the facility that
requires additional staffing
during the period of covid we've had to
maintain quarantine and isolation units
which require additional staffing um we
will
it's not uncommon to have a youth who's
sick has to be in the infirmary
we need staffing with them 24 7.
lots of the youth that we're serving
today have really intense needs
and require one-to-one support so all of
that has added up to a situation that
when you had
50 kids there it kind of came out in the
wash but now that the majority of kids
there have these unique needs that
require additional support
it gets the cost per child increases
the other things i think are really
substantial there is
the programming right the um we offer a
full service school there which i think
is imperative for these youth many of
the youth who go there catch up on their
education are able to return back to
school with more credits than they
had ever had to get towards graduation
but operating a full-scale school for
you know
15 youth is you know much less efficient
than operating a full-scale school for
60 youth the education program has been
cut back in recent years but
without compromising the subject matter
that's taught it's hard to cut it back
much further
nursing that's available 24 7 within the
facility you know when you're talking
about serving 60 youth that cost
doesn't seem so high but when you're
talking about serving 10 to 15
those costs add up i think all this is
to say that the real
cost of sysc is the staffing cost
um and second cost that would continue
even in a smaller building
so i think where that leaves us is in a
place where
the state needs to make a couple
decisions
should there be a secured facility in
the state
i think it's hard to say that you would
have zero options
for secured facility for youth in the
state of new hampshire
um we've had multiple kids who have
killed people since i've been in this
state
um i'm not sure what we would do with
those kids in a situation like that
kids who have committed some other
really um horrific crimes that i
i don't know what we would do with those
kids if we did not have a facility
so if that's the decision that's made
that we need a different facility
then i think the question is to think
about when do we decide
what that facility is certainly we can
make that decision now
about how to move into a new facility i
do think that there are so many things
happening
external to the facility that the data
today is not accurate as to what the
future need is going to be
and we would run the risk of building
something bigger than what the future
need is
if i was to be asked today how big of a
facility to build based on the current
data
i'd look at the last year and say at our
peak we needed 27 beds so
we need to build to our p but in a
couple years as the system of care is
rolled out
as the um as the jj transformation work
occurs
as the new services are put online like
multi-systemic therapy that we're going
to talk about in a minute
um we might find that that number is way
too high
and then we once again build a facility
that's too big for our needs
so i think it's clear that the state
needs to think about what is next in
terms of a secured facility
i think the question of what that
facility should be how large that
facility should be and when is the right
time to make that decision based on the
data
thank you for that wonderful summary uh
we have
just a few minutes and there are three
reps with their hands up and
so i'm gonna i'm gonna propose uh
to the to the committee members with
their hands up
um if you if you think the answer may be
a long
involved one would would you just simply
state the question
and and we'll get the answer after lunch
that way
mr ribson can think about the answer a
little bit
uh if it's a short data question uh
you know let's we can just close it out
right here but
if it if it's going to take much time
let's postpone it so that we can
break for lunch on time so
representative weiler you had your hand
up first i believe
followed by representative nordgren and
mr chair i have one with short answer
difference between committed and
detained
committed youth are they have gone
through
the process in the court has found true
that they have committed the act
it might be through a trial or maybe
through a plea agreement but the court
has found true that whatever act they're
alleged to have committed
had indeed occurred detained is when a
youth is immediately
picked up after some type of event and
they're put there oftentimes
short term pending court decision about
whether to keep them in detention
or whether to return them to the
community pending you know further court
activity
and the question to think of a little
longer um
if we could get economies of scale and
we can't get economies of scale either
we would
send these youth out of state to
someplace else even if it were a couple
hundred thousand per
youth it would still be cheaper than
what we're spending or
we bring some in from other states so we
have a little more economy of scale
that's
and that's the long question we'll talk
to that later thank you
thank you representative weiler for
framing it that way
representative norgren yes thank you
representative weiler part of my
question
is how many uh children do we have
out of state now i know we've sometimes
said them in vermont
we've had them way over in ohio um so
maybe you could just give us a little
background on that
when you have a chance sure i mean
that's that could be a quick one
um i i don't have the exact date in
front of me but last time i looked it
was about 70 kids
across all of dcyf who were placed out
of state somewhere
a lot of those kids are right over the
border though um the number of kids that
are far away is typically somewhere
around
10 or so i can try to circle back during
the break and get
get exact numbers out of today thank you
representative uh my question is
sort of the opposite of there is how
many children
do we have in these numbers who are from
out of state
if any yeah right now there are no
out-of-state kids at
or there's no vermont kids there were a
couple i have to double back there were
a couple
kids from another state who committed an
act in new hampshire who were at syse
and i'm not sure if they're still there
so i'm going to have to double check on
those but there are
i think part of your question is around
the vermont contract and right now there
are no kids
placed based on acts that have occurred
out of state okay
thank you and my other question this one
when children come into the facility
or into the into the juvenile justice
system
are you doing an assessment to
be sure that they are in the appropriate
the appropriate setting i i particularly
was thinking about
the girls and you were saying that um
you have to have a whole
unit set aside for the girls and i think
in previous years
we have talked about trying to contract
um
with um existing other programs
to take the gir to have the girls in
other programs and not not at the uh
at the sununu center which would mean
that you would have one unit that you
wouldn't have to run have we looked at
that kind of stuff
yeah there let's uh let's defer the
answer and then you can think about it
thank you and that that brings us to
11 55 are there any other questions to
be
erased before uh lunch break
i'm not i'm not seeing any so
so i uh i want to put us into recess
that'd be great finish at 3
15. so if if
we quit interrupting you and you just
said what you wanted to say
how how long do you need um
my presentation is only a handful of
additional slides probably
you know 30 minutes but then there's the
budget stuff that that karen will take
the lead on and i'm not sure how to
we're gonna we're gonna be shut down by
3 15.
okay so we're now out of recess are we
recording
yes you are okay
so so uh division three finance has
come back from its recess for lunch
before lunch mr ripson was asked some
questions he's had a little bit of time
to think about him
i'm gonna turn the floor over to him to
great thank you again for the record joe
ripsom director dcyf in my office alone
a one of the i'll take one of the easier
questions first it's just uh
some data representative nordgren asked
for the specific number of youth who are
currently out of state
um there are currently 74 youth place
out of state
of those 67 are in neighboring states
do you have a follow-up representative
now that you know the data
yeah could you thank you
could you clarify that number of 70
um it's 74 total out of state 70 was my
guess earlier but the actual number
is 74 out of state of those 67 are in
our neighboring states
which you know we have a lot of kids
right over the border in vermont
massachusetts and maine
and seven are placed further away than
our neighboring states
all right great way to start and then we
had a question
um we had a question regarding
uh you know whether whether an option is
to think about sending kids
out of new hampshire who are at sysc or
bringing youth into new hampshire into
sysc
um i think those are things that could
be explored i think there's a
there would be a significant challenge
around sending kids out
for a couple reasons um one
personally programmatically i'm not
thrilled with the facilities in our
neighboring states
um i'm i'm much more comfortable with
syse
i'm sorry my phone just started talking
to me um
second uh for purposes of detention
which tends to be an immediate need and
an immediate placement need
um traveling out of state could pose a
significant challenge and hardship
to law enforcement and folks um
the alternative of um
serving kids within syse from other
states we haven't really robustly
explored that
as i alluded to earlier in response to
one of representative ulner's questions
we do currently have a contract with
vermont to serve some of their kids
um vermont had closed their their sole
secured facility last year without
a new plan in place and had found
themselves in a situation where they
didn't have put places to put kids and
asked to contract with us
while they are currently in the process
of building a private facility
um for commitment and detention so
vermont is building their own facility
as of now we do have a contract with
them but we do not have any vermont kids
we haven't talked to other states as to
whether there'd be an interest in
something like that
so i'm not sure whether there would be
but certainly that's something that
no follow-up to that i'll move on to the
last question
which was representative i think there
may be a follow-up
or at least a related question
representative rogers
um it's not a related question it's a
new question though when he finishes if
i guess okay my question is um
about the recidivism rate in the
facility when we're talking about
um the other things that you mentioned
earlier um
i'm just curious i've heard the
recidivism rate is as high as 60 percent
and i just wondered if you confirm um
you talked about
your concern about moving them um
because of the programs
there and my concern is if the
recidivism rate is in fact that high
um is the recidivism rate is the prior
the program is actually that great
yeah so and i think so this is actually
an issue that gets delved into
pretty robustly in the audit which will
be available to folks in a couple weeks
um off the top of my head i'm not
remembering what the current recidivism
rate is but it's certainly
high and it's higher than it was in
recent years
and part of that there's a couple
drivers to that
one is that we've really concentrated
the population of youth who are entering
to only be youth who are really more
acute in their needs
so that would obviously impact the
recidivism rate
the other which i think has been
problematic is that
the changes in house bill 517
that change the way that parole thinks
about discharge
really removed from their consideration
treatment needs
and whether the youth are able to have
their needs met in the community
or whether they're in the midst of
treatment at the facility that would be
best continued
and rather is really limited to an
assessment of the length of time that
they've been there and whether they
whether they pose an immediate need
danger
to themselves or others that i think has
led to some real programmatic challenges
around being able to complete courses of
treatment with youth
and one of the things that you'll see in
the forthcoming audit is a
recommendation that
evidence-based modalities be used with
these youth which certainly would be
hard if you're trying to do it
out of the context of a place where
people could consider
the continuation of treatment needs
because most of those evidence-based
models
require certain dosage in order to be
practiced with fidelity
so i do think those are both
contributing factors to what has been a
growing recidivism
i from what i've seen i don't think that
our youth would get better care
at any of the other facilities what i
think is
also unique about new hampshire is the
way that we limit the amount of time
that youth stay there is
is completely different than how any
other state operates
so that would be another challenge
around what would happen in those
programs i'd fear that if we put
youth into some programs out of state um
you know
detention facilities out of state
commitment facilities out of state
their programming wouldn't at all align
to our three what's typically a three
month or six month length of stay based
on the
severity of the of the underlying
incident um
and they actually would not receive the
type of treatment that they need as a
result of that
did you have a follow-up because if you
don't i do
so 60 recidivism rate seems uh
pretty high i don't i don't i don't know
your stats but
how does that feel based on what you
know nationally
i am sure that our recidivism rate is
quite high i've just you know again off
the top my head i don't have that data
handy
but i do know it's cited specifically in
the in the audit report um
i think our recidivism i don't know how
it compares nationally but it's
so in this community uh
which is i'm sure a sub-specialty of
dcyf people around the nation
um is there is there sort of like
um as one state that just seems to have
come up with an a different approach
that
everyone is going oh that's the right
yeah there's there's a couple
jurisdictions that do this work quite
well
i think actually the the plans that we
have in place
are are on that path and and actually
are on the path of getting us beyond
where
this is his tires um
representative are you oh there you go
go ahead
thank you the um part of what you have
to think about is the number of youth
that are placed in this setting right
now which
comparatively nationally is very very
low compared to the number of youth in
the state as a whole right we have
on average 17 at a given time um most
and that's between detained and
committed
most states have far more per capita
youth in their secured facilities around
the country
um the the states that i've seen that do
this work
quite well new jersey was one of them
and new jersey relied largely on a
robust
behavioral health system for kids
with really specialized residential
programs to meet those kids needs to get
them
the services they need the treatment
they need to get them back into the
community
that didn't eliminate the need for
detention and commitment but it drove
down the numbers of detention and
commitment drastically
and it meant that when kids were
discharged from a uh detention or
commitment placement
that they had a place to go which was
able to meet their needs
that's really lacking today in new
hampshire although the work that's
currently underway
should remedy that when i talk about the
work that's currently underway i'm
largely talking about the work that's
happening within children's behavioral
health
to completely redesign our residential
care system
to have basically different tiers based
on clinical needs different requirements
of providers that they've never had
to uh face before inclusive of becoming
accredited programs
introducing trauma-informed models of
care introducing something called six
core
strategies to limit or reduce the use of
restraint and seclusion
um and including and this taps into one
of the questions that
senator representative wallner just
asked around the use of assessment
including the use of a comprehensive
needs and psychosocial assessment to
determine what
level of care kids actually need i found
it shocking when i got to the state that
we actually don't do that
when we make placement decisions we make
placements
i want to i want to talk to pause you
there uh
representative norgren and and walter
and and weiler they all have questions
for you
but but you sort of uh you've kind of
diverged
from my question which i think may have
just simply been new jersey
what what state is i think yeah another
state that people speak highly of which
had a comparable model is missouri
missouri's actually backslid a little
bit in recent years but they were
they were a state that was doing
something similar they're not identical
to what we were doing in new jersey in
terms of building out inc
increased clinical capacity to meet the
needs of these kids
and then being able to rely less on
things like the tension and commitment
the other thing that you were talking
about you were talking about
i think transforming the way we provide
juvenile
justice services my first question of
the day i think was around
um you have transformation
plans ready to go and does the
governor's budget
support the transformation and so i'm
getting a mixed message because
initially i it didn't sound like you had
transformation plans
and and now it sort of sounds like maybe
you do
so why am i confused
so i when you ask the ques so there are
transform
there are transformative plans underway
in terms of how juvenile justice
as a whole works in terms of how
clinical services for kids
are offered both of those things are
going to be hugely impactful
on the number of kids that enter
residential care and the number of kids
that
end up requiring a detention to stay in
a team
or commitment setting what i don't have
transformational plans are is a
redesign of what sysc should be so i
those are discrete those are distinct
questions in my mind
but they are overlapping significantly
because
the resolution of those other issues
around children's behavioral health
and how kids enter the juvenile justice
system is going to have an impact on the
utilization of sysc and other
residential programs
thank you for uh clarifying that we'll
go with representative nordgren then
weiler then walner i think that was the
order
thank you very much um
joe could you please dig down into that
number of 74
children who are out of state with such
a low population at sununu
it'd be interesting to know if
some of those kids can come back i think
we don't need that information right now
but if you could just give us some sense
of
why those children are not here
and if there are any who could be back
in sununu
yeah so those are actually there the
kids that are out of state are not out
of state
for the purpose of detention or
commitment which is the sole legal
purpose
of sysa sysc is not allowed to be used
for residential placement it's only
allowed to be used for kids who have
been adjudicated
or ordered by the court or who were in a
detention status pending
that um the kids who were placed out of
state are not
are would not be eligible for sysc what
those kids largely are are youth who
potentially could be served by in-state
residential providers
but a lack of capacity or a lack of
clinical
you know expertise to meet those needs
has pushed
those kids out of seat i would say some
of those providers
the the bordering state providers are
you know literally right on the border
and are probably providers that
would even remain part of the picture in
the future state um
you know for example there's a lot of
kids on in
settings that are right along the
vermont new hampshire border that are
used by both vermont new hampshire
you know i don't think that those are
things that are necessarily going to
change
in the future state in terms of who
those providers are but what will change
is what our expectations are of those
providers in terms of the care they
okay thank you no i i just think i
i'd like more information on the the
differences maybe
of who's aware and why they're where
okay thanks
do you want that information
representative nordgren in this budget
cycle or or
well i think it would be informational
to know if
there are other categories we could be
funding
different ways so you want an answer
sooner rather than later
yeah i would add to that
right the work that's underway folks
could take a look there is
an rfp posted right now i have to be
careful not to speak too much because
it's a live
rfp but there is an rfp right now to
fundamentally transform residential care
in this state
for the first time ever requiring all
those things i provided before and also
for the first time ever actually
requiring contracts for providers which
believe it or not we did not require
before
and made it really difficult to monitor
outcomes and to really set expectations
so i think what the hope is the plan is
is that through that procurement process
we will develop the in-state capacity to
bring most of these kids
certainly the ones far away home but
there may still be some kids and
programs that are on the border but we
would be contracting with those programs
on the border
and being able to hold them accountable
the same way that new hampshire programs
thank you representative weiler thank
you mr chairman director
speaking of recidivism you said 60
recidivism i think we close to what we
see from the prison
about 50 so i'm wondering
your graduates go on to go to the prison
and and likely
is part of the reason that sony 60 is
some of them
age out and what percentage end up
in prison anyway and unfortunately our
data doesn't
doesn't connect with the data at the oc
so i can't answer that question
but what i can say is anecdotally we do
unfortunately see young people
move on from the juvenile justice system
particularly from sysc into the adult
system
and that's exactly why this system of
care work i think is really so critical
because i don't think that we're meeting
the needs of these young people the way
that the system is currently designed
and as we redesign residential programs
i was talking about you put in those
other system of care components that
we've spoken about
we'll see those numbers change you know
speaking about
you know the experience in other states
around this um you know i certainly
don't have the data to
to draw a uh causal relationship
but as the system of care in new jersey
grew the need for
adult corrections in new jersey shrank
at a time that the need for adult
corrections in new hampshire was growing
um so i do believe that the work that we
do with young people to meet their needs
and set them up to be productive adults
helps downstream effects even in terms
of
who ends up in our correctional system
in the future
i am as hopeful as you that that is the
result thank you
so uh representative walner then earth
and rogers
so mr represent i hope that this
afternoon during some of our discussion
and it might be during the budget part
but
that you put on that you talked to us a
little bit about medicaid reimbursement
um i know that we get we do not get any
sort of reimbursement from the federal
government
at the um sununu center at this time
and i my understanding is that's because
it is a
quote corrections um facility
if many of these children could be moved
out
into community residential programs that
are more
that are therapeutic uh reimbursement
would be available
a 50 reimbursement would be available
from the feds through
medicaid is that am i correct in my
assumptions here
yeah it is correct right when the when
there's a correctional setting medicaid
is not allowed
to support that cost that placement cost
so it ends up being
overwhelmingly general funds although
svic's budget does include
some like doe education funds for the
education program but overwhelmingly
it's it's general funds and yes
community programs typically can receive
medicaid
i think what's um from a budgetary
perspective what gets difficult
is you you exacerbate and it's not a
reason not to do it because kids should
be in the least restrictive environment
that they can
that they can be in but you do continue
to exacerbate that economies of scale
issue that we were talking about before
where the the savings yielded may not
actually be as much as as folks
anticipate they will be
but i do think that maximizing medicaid
revenue and getting kids in least
restrictive environments where
clinically appropriate is always the
best thing to do
thank you your follow-up
representative two quick questions
yes it's posted on our website right now
we can forward that's fine
just send me the link sure and second
question is can you get can we get a
written definition of
system of care i heard that i hear that
term a lot in different
contexts yes um
yes i'll talk to our behavioral health
folks about trying to get a written
definition for it
but essentially it's the concept of of
how
of how you provide behavioral health
services to in this instance
okay representative rogers um yes
mr ribson if we were to um place
language in house bill 2
to call for the the um closing of the
sununu center
and for um construction of a smaller
um detainee center or smaller secured
unit
and options um are you prepared to come
back to us with your thoughts on
what this would take how long it would
take what you would want and what
kind of transformational in your
language um
kind of information you would have as a
plan i think that that many of us here
are looking at that when we look at that
some of us have been looking at it for
the past
10 to 15 years actually um but it's
something that's
that a number of people are talking
about and looking at at this point
can you be prepared to come back to us
with some of your thoughts on this or i
don't know if you already have thoughts
but hopefully i can certainly share
thoughts i think um you know it's that
decision is obviously not just mine so
i'd want to i'd want to include other
people in that conversation but
i think one of the real challenges
around downsizing it and i think it is
ultimately the right thing to do
is that in my opinion we want the
programming in the new facility to be
comparable to the programming that
exists today which means
it's not going to be it might not be all
that much less expensive
and that the amenities that are
available to you in sysc
should be available to youth in the
future state as well could be smaller
bunk
funking areas but sysc offers you
comprehensive internal and indoor and
outdoor recreational space through an
indoor gymnasium
and outdoor courtyards basketball courts
and all of that
it offers you you know a full school a
library
a full medical suite where we're able to
to meet the needs of youth
dental suite where a dentist comes in is
able to meet the kids dental needs
unfortunately a lot of the young people
who get placed there haven't had dental
needs cared for
in years before getting there and we do
a lot of rehabilitative work in that
space
and that the clinical programming is
comprehensive and probably even more so
than it is today
we recently hired a full-time
psychologist down there to redesign our
clinical programming and i'm thrilled
with the work that she's doing
unfortunately she joined after covet
started and
a lot of our priorities had to shift
during the last nine months just to keep
people
you know safe in the context of kovid
but i'm thrilled with the work that
she's doing and redeveloping our
clinical program
so i think you know if i was to be asked
what the next facility should look like
it really should have the same amenities
that the current one does but probably
would have to be smaller scale to
you know to align with what the census
is
i think that also gets complex for the
reasons i spoke about before
and that if i was asked today how big of
a facility to build i would be looking
at the last fiscal year and looking at
our highest day
and say we should build to that because
we need to be able to meet the peak
which would be about 27.
but i also believe that the system of
care work that we've been talking about
is going to drive down the number over
the future years
and if you were asking me this question
in two years it'd probably be a much
lower number than that
so i think we're at this point right now
where at least for me there's a
recognition that there needs to be a
next step
but for me also the data is a little
unclear as to what that next step should
be
so i could follow up yes ma'am um we
just have a number of studies over the
last
15 years i think that have all come to
the same conclusion that we need to
close that facility and do something
different and we've never taken that
next step
i think maybe this year is the time to
take the next step
and i guess that's what i'm asking you
is to come back to us and tell us um
instead of waiting two years which is
what we always hear
let's wait another year let's wait
another year let's win another year
and it's now 15 years later and we're
spending 12.5 million
on a facility for um that was built for
hundreds and now has
you say maybe 26 sometimes as low as
eight
i think we need to take the next step
now instead of waiting for another two
years
so i guess i'm asking you um what would
you you know instead of us coming up
with something you don't like
maybe having you come up to tell us what
that next step is instead of waiting two
years
i appreciate the question and i
appreciate the sentiment i would say to
be fair the system of care work should
have preceded any of this conversation
that should have been happening a decade
ago um and the fact that it had it
puts us at a disadvantage for making the
decisions that we need to make today
so you know i think a decision could be
made to
to move forward with this more
expeditiously and if so i'd say you need
to build
to the cap which is 27. um
but in two years if this the data will
probably look different it will probably
look more favorable
to yield us building a facility that's
more aligned with what the actual demand
is going to be in the future
as opposed to what the demand was last
fiscal year
and i thank you for your bluntness and
i'm sorry to be impatient but
so so i i want to follow up on on on one
of the implications there and i i was uh
i was kind of brainstorming with
somebody the other day are
are you familiar with the federal base
okay so so in the 70s we
we had a real big problem in the
department of defense
we had military installations all over
the nation
and every single installation uh was
feeding money into a small town
somewhere
and uh and and and became a huge part of
the
business and tax revenues of of of these
localities and so when
reducing the number of bases that we had
it was all political fighting there
weren't any solutions so
so they set up this independent base
realignment and closure commission
to kind of get out of the local politics
and get an independent group
to set up recommendations and their
recommendations would be
take all of it or none of it there
wasn't any split and
split in the baby it was just take all
of it or none of it
and i just wonder if if what your
thoughts are
are are we are we at a point where we
maybe need to realize that we need
something like a base realignment and
closure commission
to take a look at
[Music]
establishing a sure path
to doing what we know we need to do
which is to
so that that's a very leading and hard
question and i'm sorry for that
now i mean i think i think it is
absolutely time to take a hard look at
that i do think as i said before the
data is going to change in the next
couple years based on the work that's
currently happening so it's hard to make
a decision today
um to representative rogers point before
right there have been multiple study
commissions over the years that have
that have not really yielded a
comprehensive answer to this question
um so one of the things i would be
concerned about is
is repeating something like that um to
not actually yield a result
but i do think it's time to to figure
out
you know what that is and to um so you
know
something like that could be could be
worthwhile i guess i just wanted to make
okay so we're we have 19 days to finish
our
our division three work and i would like
to know
if we should be doing anything different
with year two
of this budget um to either anticipate a
realignment
or to drive a realignment plan so
if you could maybe think through it a
little bit and try to give us
sort of your your best projection of
what we should be thinking about for
fy23
um that would be great and
and if that's not enough time to
coordinate with the governor's office
let us know and and tell us what you
need
please okay
um all right so
i don't see any questions did you answer
all the
pre-launch questions i had one more that
i touched on a little bit but didn't
answer comprehensively
from representative walner about the
assessments for youth entering
residential care
that is something that was recently
procured i can't go into detail about it
because it's not yet
in final phase with governor and council
but i can talk about the concept
which is that under senate bill 14 and
under this
newly procured system all youth who are
going to enter residential care
um will have a comprehensive clinical
assessment which will include
something called the cans the child and
adolescent needs and strengths tool
as well as a psychosocial which can
advise as to whether that
clinically requires residential care and
if they do what level of residential
care they do require
for youth who are placed emergently
that's going to have to happen after the
emergent placement
but the plan the idea is that in most
instances that can be done before a
placement is made
while you try to temporarily stabilize
the youth in the community before making
that decision
that will impact sysc the other key
component of the system of care that's
impactful here is the use of a care
management entity
right now there are two nfi and i can't
remember the name of the other one that
but what they do is they use a high
fidelity wraparound model
to pull together the folks who are
important in that youth's life
to oversee what's happening not only
while the residential episode is
occurring that includes sysc in this
future state
but also more importantly to support the
discharge planning and to ensure that
when youth return home
that they have the care that they need
to remain at home
and not recidivate back into the
residential system or sysc
those key components are are identical
to the models that we used in new jersey
which were successful
in driving down the utilization of
congregate care
and recidivism within those programs so
those are components i'm really excited
about
i think they will be impactful both on
the broader residential system but also
on sysc because both of them will be
used
across the spectrum inclusive of sysc
and i think that was all the questions i
received before but if i missed any
please
remind me representative
do you have a question i i do um
when you do the assessment is done on
children who are detained as
well as those who have already been
adjudicated
yeah and it's actually broader than that
so it's
it is the the idea is that we want to we
want to understand the clinical needs of
youth when they're entering these
restrictive settings
regardless of where they appear within
the system right so it could be
juvenile justice that are going to
residential care without a detention or
commitment
it could be youth who are being retained
committed it could be used in child
protection system
it could even be youth who don't touch
either of those systems and through
children's behavioral health are
accessing that care
but the idea is that frankly these kids
no matter where they're appearing within
the system
have comparable challenges and we need
to have a uniform way to understand
those challenges
and to meet their needs one of the
really beautiful things about using a
tool like the cans which we actually
have future plans of using it in other
aspects of the system
is it creates a common language among
service providers to understand
what needs are and how to develop
treatment plans and then continuity of
care
across different aspects of the system
the other really important thing about
all of this is that
housing it within children's behavioral
health rather than housing it with dcyf
child protection or juvenile justice
allows for child protection juvenile
justice to walk away
when our delinquency issues or our abuse
and neglect issues are resolved but it
allows that family to continue to get
care through the children's behavioral
health care system
if that child still has a clinical need
to be met
what we see a lot of today and this is
going to help drive down caseloads in
dcyf
is kids that get stuck in our system
because they have a service need even
though the underlying abuse and neglect
issue is resolved or the underlying
delinquency issue was resolved
so a lot of this is about trying to get
kids and families
in the most supportive setting the least
restrictive setting the same way that we
think about kids in the enter
residential settings being in the least
restrictive setting
thank you i'm not seeing any more
questions if you want to
get get us back uh on the path with your
slideshow
i'll pull up the screen shot give me one
second
all right so we touched on a lot of this
so i'm going to just go pretty quickly
but people may have questions
we've done a lot in the last two years
we've been incredibly busy
um thankful for the support that we've
received in the past really three years
since i've been here
to do all of this work from the
legislature from both parties in the
legislature from the governor from hosts
of people
interested in this work so it's hard to
fit all this onto a slide
but just really quickly some of the key
accomplishments
um restoring kind of core functionality
of
the child protection system and further
progressing within that we talked about
the changes that are happening in intake
and how we're seeing that play out in
our data another key accomplishment was
redesigning our actuarial tools that we
use to assess risk and need in families
both at intake but actually throughout
the life of a child protection case you
use these
these actuarial tools to make key
decisions those have been redesigned
validated they need to be built into our
new
case management system which is you know
currently under development
reducing case improving processes and
timeliness for child protection
assessments
and the safety culture work and the
clinical support staff that we spoke
about before
which appears to be helping reduce
turnover
other key things that are underway that
i'm really excited about a service array
redesigned to introduce evidence-based
practices
this started on the date that the
continuing resolution ended
we issued a request for information to
the public to ask for information around
how should we be redesigning the
services that we offer to families we
received a record 40 responses to that
we then took that information and used
that to make decisions about what type
of evidence-based models we want to
bring into our system
and to start phasing out some of the
non-evidence-based practices that we've
been using for
decades the first of those things what
we call community-based voluntary
services
this was something that was funded in
the last biennium and is funded
continued in the
in the proposed budget this is i think
one of the most impactful things we're
going to do on the child protection side
of the house
and what it does is it will allow us to
refer
a high-risk family to a community
provider for that community provider to
work with that family to try to
stabilize them to prevent them from
coming back to dcyf
so let me pause on that because it's
it's complex and it's really really
important to our system
i spoke a moment ago about the actuarial
tools that we use one of them is a risk
assessment
when we conduct these risk assessments
about a third
of our families come back as being high
or very high risk meaning that there's a
high likelihood according to that tool
that they're going to come back into the
child protection system
however when we make a finding of abuse
or neglect only about 10
of those families are actually found to
have already committed an act of abuse
or neglect
a finding of abuse or neglect is really
a reactive way to respond to it whereas
assessing risk and trying to
treat risk is a more proactive way to do
it so about 23
of the families we see in a given year
are high risk but historically we would
not have been allowed to do anything for
them and we wouldn't have had a service
for them
what this community-based voluntary
services will do is we use that risk
assessment
we identify these are the families that
are high and very high risk
we refer those families to our provider
we contracted it was approved by gnc in
november with two providers waypoint for
most of the state
and the family resource center in gorham
for the north country
those providers then open up open up a
case to work with those families using
two evidence-based modalities
motivational interviewing and
solution-based case work
to try to understand and address those
families needs try to ensure that those
families
are stable and that we don't get another
call back to dcyf
we get a lot of clients and families
that come through our doors over and
over again this is a key way to break
that cycle
and when i spoke earlier representative
edwards about our ability to drive down
the number of family crises
that have kids coming into out-of-home
care this is one of the key tools to do
that
um another key accomplishment the link
is here i would suggest can you
focus if you take a breath can you take
a breath there i i
as you were as you're talking i was
thinking
about any sort of control
systems that would need to be put into
place in advance
to avoid fraud waste and abuse
so once you once you get a risk-based
actuarial risk assessment
uh you you document
what questions and answers result
to the most risk and the more risk that
you have
the more likely you are to get
additional government benefits
and so just thinking like
you know somebody who might want to take
advantage of the system
i might want to learn how to gain this
risk
assessment so that my risk score goes
way up and so you start paying for my
apartment
um i i think that's highly unlikely for
this service line this is a service line
where what you have
offered to you is a social worker who's
working with you on parenting skills
working with you on navigating you know
other systems
it's not to pay for your rent or to
provide
you know some type of concrete service
like that it's a this is a tool to try
to
understand families who are lacking the
parental skills to keep kids safe at
home
and then providing the services that
help remedy those situations
when you say services i i'm thinking at
some point those services are
considered valuable or beneficial to the
recipient
and and therefore it has an equivalent
of a monetary value
and so therefore you know thinking of
gaming the system
what why why isn't there an incentive
there to gain the system unless
the only service you think i'm going to
get is additional counseling
i don't think there is an incentive to
gain the system here
i don't think this type of service is
the type that would that would attract
that type of
that type of response from from a client
i don't think someone is going to
present as having issues of domestic
violence and substance use when they
don't for the purpose of having an extra
counselor in their house
all right no you answered my question
because i'm i'm
i i every time you hear services
i hear services i'm just wondering
exactly what the nature of those
services are
and whether they would be worth lying on
an assessment
to get them understand thank you
all right um the i put a link here for
this i think this is something worth
looking
at this is the um we put forward a
procurement forecast on a host of
evidence-based programs that we intend
to procure within the next year
one of them is currently currently out
for a bit called multisystemic therapy
there's a few more on that list i would
i do think anybody that's interested
would benefit from taking a look at that
but basically what we're doing is we're
shifting from a model that we currently
have in this state
which is that we kind of have a
one-size-fits-all approach
to clinical services to our families
recognizing that those
services are not evidence-based there's
not evidence to show that they actually
work
and that there are models out there that
are evidence-based and actually are
proven to work
so that funding forecast lists forward
five different models that we're looking
to expand into the next year
this is going to be largely um replacing
the other services that that are offered
to families
so it's there is funding in the
governor's budget
proposed budget to cover those costs but
it's not like we're building a new
service that's going to be added on top
of the old service it's a new service
that's going to be offered instead of
the old service so it's not a
it's not a fully new program or a new
new funding program in that way um
other major uh accomplishments
um we did expand foster care for youth
who choose to remain in foster care up
to age 21 in the last biennium
that our youth named that program the
hope program
as is identified in here this allows
young people who would otherwise age out
of care at age 18
to stay in foster care up to 21 if they
choose to
um recognizing that a lot of young
people who enter the foster care system
would age out are not ready for full
full independence into adulthood without
some additional support in place
we implemented another evidence-based
model called yv life set why these
stands for youth villages which is the
entity that that developed the model
this is a model for transition
aged youth to try to help them
successfully move to adulthood
work with them on whatever their
identified goals are
and in attaining those goals so they can
be independent into adulthood
um we were awarded a grant to pay for
half of the cost of that
program and the other half of the cost
is contracted with the with the vendor
and then lastly in this area we've been
very successful in the past couple years
in the first time for new hampshire
although this is not new nationally
being able to partner in with housing
authorities to get access to housing
vouchers for young people who are aging
out of foster care
trying to positively impact the the
prevalence of youth homelessness
particularly for kids who are part of
the foster care system
beyond that some other programming that
we're very excited about
um in the past few years we started up
something called the strength to succeed
program this is pure support for parents
with substance use disorder
this has been incredibly successful
we have what this does is it connects
a parent who has a substance use
disorder with another parent who has
um successfully gone through that
challenge and many of whom have
successfully
come through the child protection system
and we really find it helpful in getting
those parents
the care and support that they need so
that they can actually successfully
reunify with their kids instead of their
kids having to be
having their rights terminated and
having those young people end up in
um and you know needing adoption or
long-term foster care
the m laidac and family violence
specialist programs have been expanded
over the past couple years
the m ladakh program master's license um
alcohol and drug counselor program those
are emblatax who are
in normal times physically co-located
with our staff but right now virtually
co-located with our staff
to assist our staff in identifying
when families have substance use
challenges and connecting those
families to the right supports and
services to to address those substance
use challenges
and the family violence specialists
which are co-located in our district
offices those are folks who work with
the local crisis centers
and help our staff in understanding the
dynamics of family violence and
connecting victims of family violence
to those crisis center services to try
to stabilize
those families so we're able to keep
those kids from having to come into
foster care
roadmap to reunification is an exciting
new program we phased out an old program
that we called fair and replaced it with
this
this is a model where we have a clinical
person who is working with foster
parents and birth parents
around trying to help parents
successfully reunify
um it's really important when kids enter
foster care that we recognize those
foster parents could actually be more
than just a temporary home for a child
but actually can be a support
to the birth parent and making sure that
the child can successfully reunify back
into the home
and a lot of our foster parents are
eager to do this work but this extra
support
helps bridge those gaps and really helps
our parents get ready for this
this tough work of of trying to heal
their families and bring their families
back together again
um really excited about some of the
partnerships we developed in the past
couple years with the housing
authorities are always called family
unification housing vouchers these are
federal housing vouchers
available to families who are at risk of
having their kids enter foster care
or who are are unable to reunify because
of housing instability
so these are federal vouchers that are
specifically provided for the purpose of
addressing those issues with our
families which might lead kids to enter
care
so so i have i have to stop you there
so you just you just said there was
housing instability
potential and therefore grants that i
presume
are intended to make the housing stable
which sounds like depending on the
evaluation of a family
they may end up getting some of their
rent paid
yes this is an entirely different
program than the program we were talking
about before
this is for what's called a family
unification program a family unification
these are hud vouchers
that are available for this purpose and
we partnered with the housing
authorities to apply for these hud
vouchers
to be able to provide families who are
at risk of entering foster
care as a result of housing instability
or families who cannot reunify
because the parents do not have housing
adequate to serve their kids
and i'll let you go but i just i
i just want to believe that there are
internal controls in place
to uh anticipate the potential for fraud
waste and abuse and that
there's there's active measures in place
to make sure that these benefits aren't
abused
yes and the there's these are these are
hud vouchers there's a host of
requirements
that come in place with all of that in
addition to the requirements
around our deeming eligibility based on
their children you know
either at risk of entering care or
unable to reunify as a result of care
but the underlying um criteria in terms
of who qualifies for a voucher are the
same as the other
the other uh federally funded housing
voucher programs
thank you we spoke a lot about this so i
won't talk a whole lot but the
partnership with our children's
behavioral health system around the
system of care transformation has been
huge
and also partnerships with public health
in our division of employment and
housing security
to expand support to strengthen families
to try to prevent dcyf involvement
through their work with family resource
centers and the new kinship navigator
programs which i'm
i'm very excited about so unless there's
questions i'll move on
so key challenges ahead i do mention
here housing instability is something
that keeps coming up within our cases as
a challenge for our families
um you know i think you hear about this
in some of the other presentations as
well but
work that can be done to to address this
issue broadly is going to have a
positive impact on families involved
with child protection
we spoke about this earlier too so i
don't belabor it but recruitment and
retention of staff
um i do think that we've made some great
progress i think we have a great plan
but we still are seeing a turnover that
i'm not satisfied with
and it remains a continuing challenge
and then lastly family strengthening
programs for families prior to dcyf
involvement
um i spoke earlier about the changes we
made at intake to reform
refer more families to family resource
centers and other resources in the
community
that has a great effect of keeping these
families from getting into dcyf but what
we're finding unfortunately is that some
of those programs aren't
aren't ready to handle the the flow of
families that we're sending them they
don't have the supports
they need to handle the increased volume
of referrals that they're getting from
us
um so i think that's another challenge
that would be useful to think about
identity and tenure of the key division
leaders
myself i've been here for three and a
half years many of you know rebecca ross
who's our general counsel legislative
liaison she's been here for two and a
half years
sherry hermal's our bureau chief of
field services that is you know all of
the child protection juvenile justice
field services
she's been with us for one and a half
years in that role but 21 years of the
agency
our chief of operations marie noonan has
been in her role for two years
21 years of the agency community family
and program support again that's the one
that primarily works with our providers
and overseas contracts and things like
that
michael donati oversees that bureau he's
been in that role for three years been
with dcyf for 18.
sununu youth services center is overseen
by rhonda
chassis who previously was known as
rhonda hamault maybe to some of you
she's been in that role for two and a
half years 23 years with the agency
um professional strategic development
kimberly crowe is our bureau chief there
she's been
with that role for three years
previously the bureau of organizational
learning and quality improvement
um 14 years of the agency evaluation
analytics and reporting
by the robux she's been in that role for
just under a month it's brand new
and business information systems is
steve deguiso who's been in that role
for 14 years
what's his relationship to doit
what what what are what he what's he
doing that's
um needs to be specific for
your department as opposed to being
provided by doit
so he manages the um largely manages our
case our case management system is
called a the current one's called a
sackvist system we call it bridges
cyclist stands for
statewide automated child
information some systems something like
that anyway um
our current system is 20 plus years old
he's the person who
works for the department overseeing that
system with a couple of staff
um previously he reported to the dhhs
corresponding bureau that dave leaders
overseas um
a couple years ago that was changed to
have him again sit within dcyf although
the function is essentially the same
it's just his
his uh his reporting line is a little
bit different um but he's he and his
staff are the ones who are
responsible for managing and maintaining
that system in partnership with
the department and the oit there is a
project underway that i referred to
earlier
to update this really really antiquated
or more year old system that we're
currently using
which i think we're all very excited
about getting that done but that's a
couple years from
from realization thank you
um you know the the requests around if
there was five percent increase or
decrease what would we do with those
funds um if we did have additional
funding where i would recommend that
that money go is in two different places
um one as i referenced a little while
ago we are
um having some challenges around when we
need to make referrals out to community
services particularly to frcs
and uh i think that that network can
utilize could use some more support
which would allow us to
to feel better about those referrals
that we need to make to those services
similarly in the juvenile justice world
you know a lot of work is happening
through that system of care but there
are what's called diversion programs
around the state that aren't currently
state funded
and there's not currently really a state
endorsed model
for that and i think that is a place
where um
where if we had additional funds it
would be helpful to to put some
additional funds there
to be able to better serve kids before
they get into the deep ends of both of
these systems
decreased funding i think unfortunately
would lead to a lot of negative outcomes
along the lines of
what we saw when the budgets were
slashed 10 years ago and dcyf ended up
in the crisis position that it was
shortly before i got here
i think we would see case loads grow
quality of assessments decline
recidivism increase increased children
and out of home care decreased family
preservation and reunification
and in the long term we probably see
more families meeting the deep end of
the system
which ends up being more costly in the
long run
i think we're largely living with we're
largely living with the repercussions of
what was done 10 years ago in terms of
defunding the child protection and child
welfare system
and are just now starting to see the
data shift around
these kids and care and everything else
so i just would hate to see us go back
so just to respond to the increased
recidivism
as a cost of decrements and
that one is just hard for me to wrap my
head around given we have
such a high recidivism rate right now
and it seems like
we've spent a lot of money at the sununu
center
when i was using the word recidivism
there i wasn't thinking just sysc
i'm thinking recidivism in terms of
recurring juvenile justice and child
and also child abuse and neglect
recurring
so i'm not thinking specifically of
that's why i'm thinking about recurring
families coming through the system
that could have their needs met and
stopped from coming through the system
all right thank you for the
clarification do you do you have any
way to put a little bit more analytical
precision into
these impacts
well i mean i think a lot of these are
actually things that we report on
currently within our
our annual data book and we actually
have a new monthly dashboard that we're
posting as well
in terms of caseloads in terms of
children and out of home care
[Music]
those things are already reported on
regularly
repeats is something that we're trying
to figure out you know particularly the
repeat families who come into our
community-based voluntary services is
one that we're developing a metric for
so that we can actually track that going
forward
so yes i think that you know these are
things that were
some of them were currently reporting on
and others that we're developing reports
on
increased long-term demand you know
that's something that i think you would
have to
you would look at you know comparable um
things that to what we're actually
already reporting on in terms of
new assessments call volume to the
hotline number of new child protection
cases opening up which are metrics that
we do
that we do report on regularly yeah so
so thank you for that and i i think
we're getting close to ms rounds
talking and so the segue that she may
want to pick up is
i saw an email conversation on trying to
find
the uh right line items to put the
funding into the family resource centers
if if we were to follow the governor's
request
so so we've we've heard the governor's
request mr ribson
and i i think we're trying to figure out
which lines need
how much money and and then we have to
run it through
our process of you know figuring out
what
what we can spend and what we need to
cut so
so so we're working that uh on
great and yes i'm completed by section i
think miss rounds is stepping up unless
there's other questions
are there any questions from mr ribson
before uh
he steps away are you going to stay with
us or are you going to go back to work
but i'll still be here just won't be
talking as much
uh you can go ahead and stop or if you
want to cover this one then i can
uh share sure the only prioritized needs
that were identified within the um
within the budget
um we're around sysc there's a um
the barn roof boiler that that need to
be repaired and replaced
um the utilities i think are are funded
somewhere else they're not they're not
currently spending the sysc budget they
really belong there
so that's what these are so am i
say seeing that right that you you need
another million dollars a year
well this is a one-time cost i think one
of the challenges with sysc
is it's not just the relatively new
building that people think of but it's
this campus of
of ages and oftentimes
you know buildings that need a lot of
care to
to be maintained and this is one of
those things that
that needs to be done to maintain that
building if in fact we want to maintain
i would also mention that the barn roof
and boiler were also submitted as
capital items
and they were not approved in the
capital budget or are not i should say
are not currently in house bill 25.
that's how i should say so
representative walner has a question i
think
maybe as we transition here what my
question is about
utilities for 583 000
each year at the million dollars um
do we have enough is there when we come
to the utility line do we have enough in
utilities to
pay our utility bills over the next two
years
so we've been regularly paying the
utility bill
out of the facilities budget for the
entire department
because we've not been able to increase
the budget at sysc
to pay the utilities out of the sysc
budget
okay so if we
were to put money in this line then we
should be able to decrease it from
another line
potentially i would have to double check
to make sure that they budgeted it in
that bureau but that's where we've been
paying that
because we should only need to budget an
additional increment for increased costs
but
if the base is being paid for somewhere
else we just need to transfer the base
i will um i will confirm that and um
we'll submit change requests
for that so the part of that is just how
much is that
of that 583 is like inflation versus
the the base from previous years but
representative wallner you have another
question yes my question is so
basically what we're saying here is that
the sununu center actually cost us a
million dollars more over the biennium
than what we see in the budget
and are there any other expenses
of the sununu center that are not shown
in the budget that are being born from
by other
part other areas of the department
so i would say i don't know that it's a
million dollars a year because the
it's just the utilities that are
reoccurring the
barn roof and boiler room at one time no
the biennium yes yes for the biennium
correct
um i can get you the information on
when there are times that um other parts
of the budget are paying for
expenditures at sysc
i think for the most part the only other
time that it happens is when
um there are employees from elsewhere in
the department that have to cover shifts
at sysc because there
are not enough um
they're not enough staff on a shift and
we need to pay for the overtime
so we tend to leave the overtime where
that employee lives
regularly so if i could just have one
follow-up
yes so what that indicates to me
is that the cost it at the sununu center
is even
higher than what we see in the budget
yes because there are other places it's
being born okay thank you
i think i think for the utilities line
that's true the
the increased overtime is because of the
inability to actually fill vacant
positions for ycs if we had
if we had all of our positions filled
that are funded we probably wouldn't
need to rely on overtime from juvenile
justice probation officers
but the vacancies at sysc sometimes puts
us in a position
where we need to bring in other folks to
cover ships
filling those positions will actually
probably
cost less in the net because a full-time
yc costs less
than the overtime for a juvenile
probation officer
that's a good point joe and and we do i
think last year
for sure and i think this year as well
there are some lapsed salary funds
so that would mean if we are actually
hiring the right people in the right
department then the
overtime would be reduced in the
department that's been carrying it
that's that's correct a lot of the
juvenile justice overtime is
is that it's covering this um hiring
people for those positions has proven to
be very difficult though
um you know there's a there's a lot of
reason
sure for just wondering if we're talking
about a material amount of money
are we talking about ten thousand
dollars a year of overtime or a hundred
thousand or
something some crazy number yeah it's i
i don't know the number but i'm sure
it's material because particularly
during covid
when we had to run quarantined isolation
units as well
um the the need for overtime had
increased even more because we needed to
run fewer units
or have fewer youth on more units i
should say
so there's been more overtime needed
during that period but even in the year
prior there was overtime as a result of
not having enough youth counselors to to
work the regular needed shifts
okay so i think to the point that
representative wallner was making so
effectively is
that that overtime there was probably it
probably wasn't worth doing cost
transfers between departments but it's
it is another source and
of expenses if we wanted to know what
the true cost of the sununu center was
we would have to move some dollars over
into a cost
management system to figure it out
yes yeah okay so representative rogers
do you have your question yes how many
positions there are funded right now but
unfilled
there's quite a few i can find that i
think i have that data in an email i
just don't know if it's not in my head
i can find that for us before we finish
and
follow up are there contracted positions
there as well
the contracted positions there are a
full-time psychologist and a part-time
psychiatrist through the dartmouth
contract
and right now there are some cleaning
staff that are contracted
can you get those to us as well is the
unfunded been unfilled
i don't know if you heard her question
representative rogers was asking for
data and i don't know if miss rounds or
mr ribson would get it but
you can get when you get us the unfunded
but unfilled if you can also get us the
contracted
follow up are you are you satisfied for
now
okay because your hand your hands still
up oh all right
so this is the staffing in child
protection
um so we're going back to sort of the
beginning of the presentation from
director ribson
talking about child protection staffing
so this is representing where that
staffing is throughout the accounting
units
uh as there and as discussed before 22
the positions
the cpsw positions are unfunded in the
current budget in front of you
remind me is a foster care health
program the same thing as a fro foster
care program
or is this just like a health care
insurance program or something i don't
know
what the word health has the foster care
health program is
it was recently expanded in the last
biennium it's actually something that
the department had in the prior decade
that was cut when a bunch of other
things were cut in the child protection
budget but what this is
is nurses co-located in district offices
to help manage the physical health care
needs
of youth and out of home care there were
two
people in those positions and in the
last biennium
that was increased to have enough nurses
to be able to work across the state
um with all the youth and out of home
care
what's the right ratio for that is that
like one nurse for every
thousand people in the system or 100
people in the system
so the the right ratio is actually a lot
lower than ours under the current system
um we had a program so actually new
hampshire had this program before we did
in new jersey but when we built it in
new jersey
it was built around a ratio of one nurse
to 50 to 50 youth and out of home care
um i think utah has a similar ratio to
that the ratio here is closer to one
youth
i mean one nurse to 100 youth out of
thank you representative
is going to ask about the vacancy rates
on this slide
you beat me to it yeah i'm learning
so so do you want to tell us your
um i'll have to off the top of my head
as i shared before i think it's
somewhere in the
number of 30s for child protection
caseworkers
i'll have to check on the other roles
i'm gonna go ahead and steal the screen
sharing thing with gel
oh sure let me close mine uh i just
stole it you're good
so the next line here is the uh
pie charts which you're um accustomed to
seeing
uh you'll know several uh bulleted
points at the bottom of this slide
as to some of the changes that you're
seeing from 1819
2021 to 22-23
um we moved
the dcyf budget
um portion of this budget into
the medicaid portion of the dcyf budget
into the medicaid budget
i know that's something we've talked
about or may have come up in a question
that i've sent to kevin ripple before
um so this is not a reduction in the
dcyf budget
it's just moving those expenditures into
the medicaid budget
it was the only place left in the dhhs
budget where we were
putting federal medicaid dollars
somewhere other than the medicaid budget
every else everywhere else in the budget
similar to what you saw at new hampshire
hospital where that's now agency income
instead of federal income
we we're trying to keep the medicaid
dollars in the medicaid budget
and so that's why you see that reduction
here from the 150
to the 139 and also
the related decrease in federal funds
so is this medicaid shift does that
account for the 45 million or so
completely a vast majority of it the
other
things that it um is related to are the
two bullets there which is what um
joe had been talking about earlier that
ssbgn and the kinship program have been
moved to economic and housing stability
which is
um one of the family resource center
programs that we've been talking about
the rest of the parental assistance
programs were moved to the
department division of public health
services as an
prioritized need which you'll hear about
uh later next week
but those are also on the list from the
governor
all right so with that we can jump right
into the accounting
units the first one is 29.56 which is on
page
this does start at the bottom of page
933 just after
my eyes blur a little bit which which
title are we looking at right now
um we are in 2956 which is
dash dcyf it's the very first accounting
unit of
so there's a fairly significant jump
going from fy21 to fy22
yes this is mostly due to um
the position increase rebecca can you
just speak to what positions were moved
into this accounting unit and perhaps
where they were moved from
or were they converted um
there is four positions that are moving
from
what is currently known as the bureau of
organizational learning
bulky that's 2960 they
and then there's one position coming
from juvenile justice
so it's a legal person and then it's
part of a
new piece and that would be on
a slide that joe had shown previously
um
his general account i'm sorry his
general counsel legislative liaison
group so these are just
going sorry these are just being moved
they're not
new positions could you could you help
us with just
like a little cheat sheet to show you
know
where these plus ups where they're being
subtracted from other parts of the
budget just so we can see the
debit equal the credit he actually
already provided that for the whole
department so kevin should have that
already
i think i sent that out in one of my
emails and it's also on the division
i can't hear you chair no i'm saying
you're
you're great you're all over it thank
so if there are no other questions there
the next accounting unit is 29.57
which is uh child protection this is
where
the child protective
cpsw positions are
this this shows a fairly significant
increase
from fy 21 to
fy23 it goes up
like four million dollars yeah
um but in this current biennium we had
sb6 which provided us more supervisors
and
cpsw staff that was in its own
accounting unit the dollars were only
allowed to be used for that specific
purpose
and this biennium going forward we're
putting all of them
in the same accounting unit they all
representative irf yeah
could you just refer to which number
that was kevin
that the document is that she was
talking about on the last slide which
also relates to this one i think moving
positions
i don't know that it referenced a
specific question however
how about this the thing labeled fy
position compare
i think it's the one labeled dhhs
physician movement
so on the web page at least it's the
last item that's listed
okay i'll go back and try to find it i
thought i had them all here thank you
yep
the next accounting unit is 29.58 uh
this accounting unit is where all of the
services related to dcyf uh
child protection live this is where
you'll note that 535
was the medicaid expenditures that have
been moved so that's why you're seeing a
big 30 million dollar expenditure now
the same with um quest 563
it's also moved to medicaid okay thank
you
so representative earth your hand is
still up do you have another question or
no all right keep going i don't see any
the next thing coming in is 2959 which
now it looks like an fy18
which you don't have it was
it was really pretty small and then
from fy20 to fy23
it looks like it really hasn't changed
much
small percentage increases
is that is that because we haven't had a
growth in domestic violence or
what i mean i'm i'm just curious
that that line item hasn't grown as
aggressively
so this is an area that i know that the
governor made purposeful investments
last biennium and fiscal year 20 and 21
which is probably why you're seeing
lower expenditures in some of those
earlier years
um so that that's what i
would say i don't know if joe has
anything else to add to that
now i think they're also a big a big
piece of it is also federal funds and um
you know federal grant funding that you
know are
are not driven by our decisions but
driven by what
what formula grants apply to new
hampshire
yeah now i see that the federal funds
are growing faster than our general
funds
representative
you're on mood sorry um
is there a is there a match requirement
no there's not okay thank you
still up representative i'll put it down
moving on to the next account accounting
units 29.60 which is
the organizational learning and quality
improvement
the next accounting unit is 2961
this is why we see the big jump from
fy20 to
fy21 because we we went
and hired some nurses to look after our
foster care settings
that's correct and please um
rebecca correct me if i'm wrong i
believe we earn
medicaid admin on this and it is a
higher than 50 50 if i
recall correctly correct
back to 29.60 the travel of state
traffic
so i think representative weiler your
your microphones on do you have a
question about travel
the uh yes in 2960
do you want to speak to how that bureau
may incur
out-of-state travel well this is
um this is the bureau where all the
training costs
are kept for the division um so
my my assumption is that that is the
those are the the those are associated
with training costs
i'm not sure rebecca are there other
travel costs in there beyond training
um there's a few conferences
that uh staff would attend
it was one of the prioritized needs for
the current biennium and it wasn't
funded
so i think joe is saying this is for his
entire division so it's for all
400 500 employees yeah actually i think
it's closer to 700
yes it's it's sorry 700. it's um
this is this is the training the
training costs for the entire division
follow-up representative
i guess i guess all the training is done
out of state
there's a lot of training that's
required it's not all done out of state
there's a lot of training done in state
but um
but there's a lot of training that is
i'm not seeing other questions do you
want to continue
um i think we were on 29.61 all right
health program i don't know if there are
that's what representative earth does
representative earth you have a question
yes the 80 percent increase does not
in 2961 foster care health program
general funds went from
looks like i see 367 000 431 432 000
roughly
in the budget this was because of the
new positions
the new nursing position okay i
yeah um the chairman mentioned that but
i just see 19 for the permanent
classifieds
all the way through should there be
different numbers in there
i think they weren't funded in fiscal
year 20.
they didn't get funded until 21 if i
remember correctly they got added to the
total budget but they didn't get funded
until the second year of the biennium
right but i'm looking at the second year
the biennium costs and that's the thing
that jumps
into the first year of the the total
cost
also goes up as well though
i'm not questioning that okay so the
general funds would have to go up
if the total cost is going up because we
don't the earned percentage
that's not the question i'm asking karen
if you said you added the person
in 21 that's this year yeah
and that total is three that annual
total is 367.
yes and that includes that person
correct yes
or did you just have that person late in
the year or something so you're saying
and so if if you look at this screen so
that you're saying here it's 367 and
then it goes to 431
correct why is that increasing yes okay
so the total costs go from 1.4 million
to 1.7 million
and the general fund earn is about 25
this federal funds are 75 the general
funds are
25 so that the
total percentage on the total didn't
change
it's the total cost that went up it
okay which is maybe that's the right
answer because it's not related to
people if the people stay the same
well this right the salaries increase
because of step increases
the benefits increase because of pay
increases
so the step the step this time was
between
this year and next year
and then there's oh then there's another
step every year that's the 5.6
and then also fiscal year 23 has an
extra pay period
okay and part of the reason that this
might be a larger jump in some
other areas is these were all vacant
positions
and when they're vacant they're budgeted
at step one
so if we hire any higher if we hire them
at a higher pay
because of their experience or or their
education
then that's going to make this first
year number higher okay
thanks sorry
well those good questions thank you um
okay i think uh we can move on to
juvenile field services
um i don't think we
i don't think we got all the way through
these accounting units
i was i thought juvenile field services
was next
it's not good go to your next i'm just
looking at
my no i don't believe so so the next one
was a workman's comp
uh which as i've discussed we moved to
ocom
um oh hold on sorry
so then workling.com 2967 should be the
2967 which is child welfare services 4b
i'm looking at the spreadsheet that you
put together
off of the dhh baseline
dhhs fy 18-23
yep and it looks like i'm maybe missing
this account so that was based off of
the uh
spreadsheet used in the department's
briefing book which only had accounts of
a million dollars or greater
so a smaller account wouldn't be in
there
okay so there there are there is that
line accounts less than a million
dollars
so all right
okay so we're on accounting unit 2968
federal
okay the next one is 2969
the next accounting unit is 2970 which
is teen independent living
that continues on to page 944 also 100
federal
independent living i i didn't think we
had an emanci
emancipation program in new hampshire
how does
how's it how does a teen legally end up
living independently i guess after high
school or
who are these teens these are this is
this is some of the federal funding used
to support
transition-aged youth right so
typically these would be 18 year olds
right who are transitioning from foster
care
okay and then we've extended the ability
to for foster
care to to voluntarily go to 21 is
another way of
of handling it yes okay
representative if you have a question
just a general question there's about a
half a dozen of these all federal fund
uh accounts so the federal government
basically just say
we want to have these kinds of things
done and here's the money for it
yeah they're they're largely formula
grant funded
so these different types of programs
where the federal government puts some
some restrictions around how the funds
should be used and then
divvied up by the states based on you
know
per capita thank you
the next accounting is 29.71 adolescent
aftercare
which is also 100 federal
joe what is aftercare um so aftercare is
typically
um it's typically less money used for
youth who are still having some
challenges beyond the age of
you know when they would age out of the
system so these are not kids who are
actively in the foster care program or
kids who are
um you know who we're providing you know
direct support for but
um they could be kids who have aged out
of the system who who have some type of
you know short-term discrete need um
again these are kind of federal funds
thank you the next one is 29.72 which is
adolescent
purchase services this is 100 federal
funds
questions
okay the next one is 2973 which is
promoting safe stable families
how do we promote safe stable families
what what what what's like the main tool
in our
our toolkit for promoting safe stable
families is this counseling
or is it something else you know i'd
have to
the all with all of these grants being
relatively small amounts of money with
overlapping
um missions a lot of them are used to
fund
um you know the same programs i'd have
to go back and look at exactly which
grants are funding which programs
but some of these funds are used to do
foster care recruitment and things like
that some of these funds are used for
supporting our adoption
our adoption program we have the adopt
nh.org where people can learn about kids
who are legally free for adoption
some of these funds are used to to fund
portions of some of our other
programming um
i'm trying to think off the top of my
head um
i'll have to double checking it back to
you but there's they they tend to just
cover a small piece of of other
programming because they are relatively
small dollar amount grants
sure between the two years it's it's
1.3 million so it's it's almost like
real money
yeah but you can't build a you can't
build a comprehensive system with it
right you can
no i know i'm just curious what it is
but it's not urgent that that that can
be
you know as we approach summer and we
need
something to talk about um if i could
just add
that um on the key accomplishments
on the presentation that joe provided
on the last one the road map to
reunification
the partnerships um some of these
dollars go to fund
part of those contracts yes
all right i think we're ready for the
next the next one is 2974 which is
adoption services
again my eyes are having a tough time
focusing because i'm using the screen
it's uh i'm not i'm not seeing any
okay so it's a it's it's basically
a little less than two hundred thousand
dollars a year yes 195
so one day i'd like to have a a
conversation
about what we can do to
help the adoption process what we can do
what what what what the challenges are
with
with getting kids adopted and um
and what we might be able to do to
facilitate that whether it's
making the legal process easier or
or something i just i'd really like to
talk about the adoption where we are
with the adoption system
we we we can we can make that a may june
conversation
okay next next accounting unit 29.75 is
uh no longer
being used and the same is true with
which now does um wrap up
the child's protection area
so if i go back over here to the slide
deck
that was the last accounting unit eating
and the next area is juvenile
justice which is made up of 108
employees
the total budgets are as follows
not much changing from year to year
other than
so so this is under the general title of
juvenile field services so there are two
accounting units
associated with this the first one is
on page 953
where is the field is the is the field
all over the state they travel all over
the state
or is the field these folks work at
three or four
facilities these folks work at the
district offices throughout the state
and they serve families throughout the
state
[Music]
there are their homework fame as the
okay so the first accounting unit is
79.05 which starts with page 953 and
i'm not seeing any okay the
other accounting unit associated with
this area is 7906
which is ojdp um
which if i recall correctly joe is a
uh grant yes
and does this grant is this the one that
has a committee associated with it that
determines how the funds are spent
that's correct yeah the state advisory
group
questions
all right go back over to the slide deck
um and the last bunch of accounting
units so i think we'll meet your 315
deadline hopefully
chair um is sysc
this uh shows the total positions what i
would note
is there have been several reductions in
positions over the past several
bienniums
and those positions have not been
abolished they've only been unfunded
so when you look at the total positions
you see those
22 positions in the position count but
there are no fun
there is no funding for those 22
positions
and if if you're looking at the
comparison from the agency phase to the
governor's phase
um we did accidentally fund some of
those in the agency phase and the
correction was made in the
governor's phase it was just a accident
sure so so what is the decision
that needs to be made if we're not going
to fund a position
why do we carry the head count or the
fte count still
why not just reduce the number of
recommended
positions there's i
i wouldn't necessarily say we need all
these unfunded positions i will say
there is value to having some unfunded
positions in areas where there are
smaller
numbers of staff unfortunately that's
why i see we do see a lot of
folks go out on you know medical leave
injury things like that
um you know for example um you know if
if we lose a maintenance staff or or
something like that as a result
of uh you know some type of injury or
medical leave those grounds are so large
and complex that we can't really live
without those people for too long and
being able to
fund an unfunded position is a lot
easier than creating a new position
um so i think there's there is benefit
organizationally to being able to have
some of that
certainly right having 18 unfunded
positions of education are never going
to be
you know that's not necessary let me
just comment
go ahead in the last budget as a way of
keeping the hhs down at the time they
had a whole lot of
vacancies so what what the last budget
did more or less was freeze the number
of positions you have
and gave them flexibility to okay
you really need to hire this person who
just left you can replace this position
with that position and come before
fiscal to tell what they had done and
it was a regular thing on fiscals to say
well we
moving these three positions to these
three positions so basically it was
a way to keep the spending down in hhs
it's not a normally used thing so you
had a lot of
positions that were if you will
funded but not filled because they
really weren't funded
until another vacancy came available
somewhere else
that was just a gimmick first time we
used it thank you
thank you across the department you will
see in the budget bill that we have
abolished one position
this um this biennium it's a medicaid
position
um so that's the position that's been
abolished and it's being replaced by
another position
uh you could call me superstitious but
we had um
three employees in a row pass away while
in that position and so we decided to
retire that position number and create a
i know a little strange call me
superstitious but it was just too
strange to have three employees in a
rail pass away and unexpectedly
if the number was 666 or something
it wasn't it wasn't there was no reason
to have suspicion before
so so that's the only position abolished
in the department
okay any questions
so uh the pie charts show that
the budget was essentially level funded
from 18
19 to 20 21
there were layoffs at the end of 1819
to achieve that level funding there was
also
a back the budget cut in house bill one
that specifically related in addition to
our department-wide budget cut
but excuse me back of the budget cut
there was an
additional back of the budget cut that
specifically related to sysc
excuse me all right
thank you the additional other funds
that you're seeing here
are potential funds um from vermont
which
may or may not happen from what ops did
you say ops
no the state of vermont and the contract
that we have with them
so the first accounting unit in this
uh starts here sort of at the middle of
the page which is the
sysc director's office
uh this is an area as i've mentioned the
unemployment
um and with comp we keep within the
facility
because the workman's comp especially
can be very unique
to the facility um injuries are very
different than
somebody like me who's in an office so
we do keep those
separately within the facilities budgets
we don't
so really the next one is 7913 which is
okay so so that had a bit of a jump is
that related to the
barn slash roof
i think it was more just trying to
budget at the level
that we've experienced in fiscal year 20
they spent about 35
000 so we budgeted 37. um
[Music]
rebecca was there any other reason that
that
no just um potential increasing costs
this is
um an area where we um this is our
warehouse
and we uh it's hygiene products for the
kids
so is this these these are this is
material management for the sununu
center or
so this is one that actually should be
really correlated to
the number of people that are uh being
guests of the facility
the next accounting unit is 1203 which
okay so someday if i ever were to ask
you what the average
cost of each meal is you'd be able to
so we can come fairly close because at
one time we were providing meals to
another part of the facility for a
contractor
so we had come up with estimates so if
you want we could provide you
what we had come up with at that time
i'm going to be we're going to be asking
you a bunch of stuff this
that would be an an interesting trivia
question
uh representative weiler has a question
now one time before we uh opened the new
sununu center
the meal costs were much lower then they
opened the sununu center and the meal
costs went up
high it was because you had a almost a
24-hour
kitchen or cafeteria as it were
are we still maintaining that cafeteria
for the
dozen kids that are there
there there does remain a cafeteria in a
food service it's not running 24 hours
serving three meals a day does it serve
three meals a day
yes it's probably 18 hours or so
how many meals a day are they serving
depends on the census but you know three
million
we'll have a full staff
yeah the there's the the staffing there
has been reduced over the years from
what it was
um but yeah there are staff there to
prepare
those three meals a day seven days a
week 365 days a year
probably four or three yeah that sounds
about right
i think there are you know how many are
full i think there might be four
filled four positions
six positions but i think going back to
here
there are six and one is unfunded
currently
and i think one's vacant and not without
the intent to fill so i think it is for
better actually
uh representative weiler your hand is
still up i assume you're done
karen i was wondering you were showing
that on the prioritized needs you needed
another half a million dollars each year
for
utilities where would that where would
that
show up if we were i believe that
shouldn't show up i believe that would
be in the next budget which
would be 7914 maintenance is that
correct rebecca
representative earth are we on 79-14
yeah that was actually a question i had
earlier i i didn't have material
management maintenance separated when i
was looking at this
that's why i was asking about the barn
slash roof i was looking at the the
increase there from this year to next
which is the maintenance can you speak
to the increase in current expenses
and yes um
[Music]
the increase is due to the
cleaning contract that we have or the
extra cleaning due to the cobid
wouldn't that have been included in this
just unauthorized well it wasn't
something that
um we had budgeted it was something that
we had to do because of
the covid right but i'm looking at the
adjusted authorized just under 700
000 and then i'm looking at next year's
recommended it
a bit under a million nine fifty
thousand am i looking at the right line
the total for that compartment
uh right it's it was it it's in the
actual
i'm a little confused i'm looking at 21
to 22.
okay so there's no cost in there for
the cleaning contract that we currently
have
to because of cobid
there's no cost in the 21 actual i mean
adjusted authorized
for the cleaning is that correct okay
but there is in the next
budget yeah yeah so all the money you
spent on cleaning this year
where is that where does that show up um
well we are going to have to move money
to
pay for that this is just the adjusted
budget at the beginning of july so you
wouldn't see any expenditures
right now oh so this suggested
authorizes as
way back to july no yeah yes
okay i guess i need to understand what
adjusted authorized means okay
why it means july well that's the
beginning of the
that's the beginning of the budget year
i wonder what they're adjusting at that
point
that even started
and it doesn't change until we go to
so i think we can go on off of
maintenance
to help i think it's health services but
correct
these are health services for who who
are the beneficiaries
the youth in the facility so i believe
this has nursing
24 7 nursing staff for the facility as
well as
the contracted dental services
physician services um psychiatric and
psychological i think they're here too
right rebecca the the dartmouth
the psychologist um correct as well as
um drugs prescriptions for the kids
all that type of stuff so that's 2.5
million
throughput in a in a given year of
i i don't think i fully heard that
question either no i'm trying to figure
out the math how much were
health services we're paying per uh
child that transitions through the
facility if our
if we if we put about a hundred distinct
individuals through
sununu in a given year uh 1.3 million
works out to be about 1300 per
uh resident you know and that that would
just be an average
it's am i missing some math it just
sounds like
you know it sounds like a pretty decent
amount of money
i think this is a place where again
those economies of scale have really
impacted to operate 24 7 nursing
um staff for fewer for fewer youth so
when you try to calculate it by use days
it adds up you guys ever
looked at telemedicine as a way of
providing some of your health care staff
so that you don't have to have physical
bodies on site all the time
i'd be i'd be anxious not having a nurse
in the facility given some of the
challenges that we see with
with our young people um you know i
don't know that our
youth counselors or others would be in a
position to kind of provide that type of
i would say it would also potentially
increase our medicaid expenditures
because it
probably would increase a child being
taken to the hospital so then they'd
have to be transported to the hospital
and then
many of the children are medicaid
medicaid would then be charged for the
services
um and as we know hospitals charge more
than what probably what we could provide
their services for
okay representative weiler you had your
hand up sir
yes thank you both in 79 14
and 79 15 we've got agency income
that we didn't have a 20 and 21.
what did we suddenly start collecting
the money for the vermont contract for
the kids that
we potentially might have that's where
those two areas
we we budgeted those dollars so if we
don't get the kids
then we would potentially need other
dollars to
fund those
[Music]
could i just understand a little clearer
what
rebecca just said so are you saying that
we're budgeting
in five a half a million
but if we don't get it from vermont if
that doesn't come
we will have to replace that with
general fund dollars or spend less
yes or spend less in this category
yes or or in i mean
if we needed to move funds from
somewhere else in syse and spend
less than somewhere else in there um
[Music]
or potentially from somewhere else in
the department which i know
in past years there's been a wording in
house bill 2 to say that we um have to
come to fiscal committee to transfer it
even a dollar into sysc
so it would come to fiscal committee if
that language was there again which i
assume it will be
you have another question you both how
about you representative uh
how many kids from vermont was was
possible in that contract
the contract had a ceiling of six at a
given time but that was
we know that it will i i would be
shocked if it ever reached that ceiling
i think it's much more likely that we'll
see
between zero and two kids there at a
given time um
was just developed to make sure that we
had the capacity in case there was
um additional need a lot of
kids that went with pain we budgeted at
the one to two
kids level we didn't budget at the total
of six knowing that that would be
unlikely
yeah i think rebecca do you remember
what the daily rate is that we're
charging them it was based on
a calculation of the state fiscal year
yeah um i want to say it was over a
thousand dollars a day
i'm not 100 sure it was yeah i think it
was
over i thought it was over 12 or 13 but
um
yes are there other areas in this budget
scheduling vermont money
to come in this isn't the only area
where you would
um go ahead i'm sorry the funds
um for the vermont revenue potentially
were only budgeted in two class lines
the the current one sorry the 7914
and then um in the one that we're just
discussing 79 15.
okay so in 79 14
there was 200 and is that 230
000 that you scheduled from vermont
correct and then another 500
000 in 508
correct okay so uh three quarters of a
million dollars
each year is in this budget as
revenue that's coming from vermont that
we don't really know whether we're
getting
correct okay thank you
if i might just say so you know um
there is other revenue budgeted within
sununu but that is
for um from doe for the meals
um and then the school any
um if a child has an iep then we can
questions i think we can go on
all right the next one is 7916 which is
i'm not seeing any questions actually i
is that current expenses
just like curiosity what does that mean
rebecca what are the current expenses of
system i mean they're typically supplies
um but what are they here um
i'm going to have to
get back to you on that this is out of
79 16.
yes yeah i don't i mean i don't know
what they are just curious as to why
there's a
what twenty percent jump and then a 16
fiscal year 22 is pretty much in line
with what we actually
spent in fiscal year 20. it's 250
more um but we can get back to you on on
what that includes
any other questions i think we can
proceed
this is one of those areas that rebecca
was mentioning about the funds that come
i'm not hearing any questions so the
very last accounting unit is 79
that looks like that's all federal money
it is correct
i believe those are the other funds you
were talking about that come from doe
this is the title one grant that comes
from
are there are d.o.e any other questions
because that looks like it may wrap up
the accounting phase
it does and that is also the end of the
slide presently
so we have two or three members i forget
oh
uh go ahead representative what's your
question
so if you know that we we know that the
cost
of running sununu is is very high for
per child what what do we know about
cost in other states
where do we where do we fall in the cost
per child for running a detention center
like this
um where do we compare is are we high
are we low are we in the middle
i'm positive we are high in the cost per
child
calculation i don't have i don't have
that data to point to but i
i'm sure that it will point to us being
high again i think
right that i know that folks like to
think about this in a cost per child
way but i think what's difficult is that
when you do the work
to keep children out and reduce your
economies of scale
that you're going to inflate your cost
per child i think it's you know it's
other states we are incredibly low in
the number of children detained and
committed compared to other
jurisdictions as well
and i i'm not advocating to shift our
policy to detain and commit more kids to
resolve this problem
i'm just saying that i think you know
it's not an apples-to-apples comparison
if you're comparing a state that detains
and commits
many many kids to a state that detains
thank you you have a follow-up there no
so okay so i think implicit and in some
of what you've said through the course
of
the day so far mr ribson is that the
personnel
costs that are associated with providing
these services
are fixed regardless of how many
residents there are in the facility and
um and i'm i'm just wondering if we can
afford
a system that is offering services
for such a small number of kids that if
there can't that there must be some more
efficient way to say provide library
access or to provide
meals or i i i just
i just don't want people to get
comfortable with the idea
that our personnel costs are
fixed they're only fixed in the short
term
so we need to be thinking a little
longer
um so so i just wanted to say that
yeah i i i do not disagree i think um
the personal costs are not entirely
fixed right the
the yc's are the most youth counselors
are the most fluid position based on
you know daily need and that does get
very complex if you think back to the
slide that i showed around
the average daily census and how it
could swing you know double
in a day and then collapse in half in a
day
that gets that makes staffing very very
complex
um but those costs will
change with the census somewhat and
again it's not exactly the census but
it's the number of units that need to be
run to serve those children
that really drives that cost the other
car for me
what was that it's a step increment you
get to step you gotta
add more costs yeah but it's it's even
more complex than that because it also
right you could have one child who
requires a coach with them all day
a one-to-one supervision all day and
that's going to be that's dependent on
that child's needs when they show up
and that need may change over time is
that child stabilizes
but they're very unpredictable costs so
i think that's
that's a real challenge with managing a
facility that is
um that is as high acuity as this is
um some of the other costs that are more
fixed in the current structure are the
education program the nursing program
those types of things
i want to ask you about your use of the
word acuity you you used it earlier
i i'm used to acuity being used in a
patient care
context to refer to the acuity of a
patient
that and so i'm just imagining that
since these are detained kids and
committed kids
that by acuity you mean some tend to be
more violent than others
or need yes and no sometimes it'll
manifest as violence but but
most of these kids do have complex
behavioral health needs
um very few of these kids are are you
know
are are absent some type of complex
behavioral health need on top of the
other challenges that they have
so sometimes it manifests as violence
and sometimes not i wouldn't say that
it's always violence that we're
not concerned about when i say that it's
um
it's really what their needs are and how
intense their needs are
okay um all right so
are there any other questions i i
i'm not seeing any i i know we have
two or three reps that need to get on to
their next
event um and uh
and you all are welcome to go when you
when you want we're going to open up to
the attendees to see if anyone has any
questions
if those who have to leave um
can stay just for a little while to
listen to some of them um
but you'll know that this is on uh being
recorded so
you can come back and listen to the
question and answers uh
at your convenience representative
walner did you have a question
no thank uh i just wanted to know if we
were gonna have audience participation
at this point
i'm trying to integrate that now and and
for those of you who are leaving
um please take a look at your email i
proposed
some work sessions next week and then
after i wrote that email
mr ripple let me know that we've got a
couple of bills that got
referred to finance and i think are
making their way to
division three for us to be second
committee on
so so we have uh the good fortune of
having more work here in the next 19
days than we anticipated
so um i'll get you
we'll get some information to you about
that we'll i'll try to ask the policy
committees for
any good good testimony that they got
so that we can get ahead of the game a
little bit
but um so
uh representative rogers you're you're
speaking but you're on mute
did you have something to say ma'am
all right okay so uh
i see a question from mr dejoy uh do you
want to bring him in
mr ripple yep he should be
yeah he should be allowed to talk now
okay so before you get started uh i
don't know how many people are going to
want to talk
but but i think we're going to try to
keep a three-minute timer on people and
ask that you keep it
uh your comments related to a resourcing
issue and not a philosophy issue
so you you may speak
thank you mr chairman i have i have a
brief statement and i hope
i can stick to your resource
criteria i just want to start by
applauding the department uh for their
work in the probation transformation
that was mentioned previously
as well as the transformative work
around the system of care
that's integral with child protection
but it's also a linchpin
of the juvenile justice
system as well my comments are
in relation to the sysc discussion in
the sysc budget
waypoint has been working for the
closure of sysc for a number of years
now
but the newspaper articles this past
tuesday
and the extent of the alleged abuse at
sysc has raised this conversation to a
new level
for the past six years we've undertaken
at waypoint
many efforts to try to engage the
department in conversations about next
steps
and try moving away from the
correctional model at sysc
but that has not been effective the
system
today at sysc operates essentially the
same as it has since it opened
um and that's part of what we're talking
about as far as the the costs
is the the model and the structure
the only legislative effort that has had
significant impact
is house bill 517 which dr is what
dropped the census in large part
from in the mid 60s to where it is today
these are 100 percent nearly 100 percent
and as the number of kids committed to
sysc has decreased
the budgets continue to increase and the
question for us remains is this the
least restrictive setting and the most
clinically appropriate facility for
children
i think we have before us or more
appropriately you have before you
an opportunity to transform this
facility and transform the treatment for
some of the most complex
children children with some of the most
complex behavioral health needs
in the state our neighbor to the west
vermont
has undertaken a similar effort just in
the past year
they closed woodside which is their only
juvenile corrections facility
around august or september of last year
and we can learn
a significant amount from their efforts
they've grappled with some of the same
issues that we've been talking about
here today
and i i would note that they recently
signed a contract with a private
provider
that the new facility will be open
i'm told by a legislator in vermont by
the end of this calendar year or just
over a year
after the decision was made to close
woodside
just a couple of points to keep in mind
about the children we're talking about
these are not hard and criminals these
are children
by the department's own estimate nearly
of these kids have behavioral health
needs typically complex
behavioral health needs and the one
thing we know for sure is that
every child in the juvenile justice
system by the time they turn 18
is returned to to their community or
another community for them to live in
um so so john that
that that's that's three minutes but i'm
not seeing any other hands
so so maybe you got another three
minutes but
um thank you mr chan hopefully i won't
need it i think i need about another
minute
and a half so thank you um
the conversation about recidivism was
was very interesting
and the 60 number is what i've heard as
well
that number tracks pretty closely with
juvenile justice
programs across the country
interestingly as well as
adult correctional facilities across the
country
so in addition to the budget that you're
talking about you also have house bill
254 that will be before you
uh momentarily this is a bill that we've
advanced that
like house bill 517 further restricts
the kids that can be committed to
sununu this bill along with the
transformations that have been mentioned
through families first and the system of
care
um position us
to have fewer and fewer kids at this
facility
and make the opportunity for change
what i would point out is that across
the country in juvenile justice
when significant change is made to
facilities such as sununu
it is not made by the managing agency or
in this case dcyf
across the country changes are only made
and closures and specifically are only
made
through legislative mandate court
mandate
or occasionally through chief executive
we waypoint does not find the sysc model
to be in the best interest of children
and it's clearly costly for taxpayers
we believe that now is the time to close
sysc and focus on treating children
with the most complex behaviors in more
clinically appropriate
settings for this to happen
it will require a definitive
pronouncement by the legislature
and with that i'll conclude my comments
so so mr dejoy thank you so much for
your comments
um i i used to be in the in the military
and what we would say
to our soldiers oftentimes was
you know uh thank you for bringing me a
problem
now bring me a solution and and
i would i would uh put the same on you
sir
just to say uh i think i think
there's probably broad agreement that
something needs to be done and the real
question gets to be
exactly what is that something so to the
extent that you can help
clarify that with some an option or some
options it may be a future date
that would be really great
mr chair i'm happy to share that i have
i have
a an example of a developed option that
i'm happy to share with you in the rest
of the division
what i would point out is that what i'm
going to send to you
is an option it is not the only option
may not even be the best option but it
is an illustration of a way that we can
get to where i'm talking about and the
department may have
um may have better ideas than that and i
i would be open to
working with the department on those
ideas
all right well great so you so who are
you going to send your
mr ripple yeah that'd be great
if you have his address that's the email
address that's great
yep yep and and uh in an effort of full
transparency
transparency i'll send it to uh mr
ribson
and as well mean i i did i didn't
mention it but
uh i i i try to ask if somebody's a
lobbyist to introduce themselves as a
lobbyist and i believe you are sir
i am a lobbyist i'm actually an employee
of waypoint but i
i do work in their advocacy department
and i am a registered lobbyist for
i i see representative nordgren with her
hand up
i might just comment that john is also a
former member of the house
so are we supposed to hold that against
him or or is that good
i would just use that as part of his
background in
doing what he's trying to help us do
today thanks
i would note on that if i could for
context the very first budget i sat on
was the inaugural budget for um
the new services center oh so we have
you to blame
uh in in some measure i think that's
accurate
so okay so mr ripson i'm sorry that was
there's a little lightheartedness there
it's a heavy subject i
i don't i don't want to um have uh mr
dejoy's
words hanging out there without giving
you an opportunity to respond
however you care to thanks you know i
as i think we've said here um and as
i've said here multiple times i think
um it's obvious that a decision needs to
be made about
what's next for um secured uh you know
detention and commitment in this state
um i do believe that the the ongoing
efforts that mr joy spoke about are
going to
continue to drive down the need but that
isn't going to i do not believe
that it will eliminate the need i don't
think we've seen a single jurisdiction
in this country be able to eliminate the
need we've seen people
um talk about closing a facility in
vermont only to open up a private
facility
san francisco made big headway when they
announced closing their juvenile
facility
but their plan was to transfer those
kids to the state facility
missouri closed a lot of facilities new
jersey's closed a lot of facilities but
they moved them to other facilities
nobody's actually been able to eliminate
the need
so i think you know it the idea that
there's a closure
without a step two is is a very very
risky
dangerous proposition um and i think
that you know it's
it would be risky to jump into demanding
that something closes at a certain point
before a plan is in place um
to have whatever is saved whatever we go
to next
i i just just so you know from a
personal perspective i couldn't agree
with you more
as a as an old plans officer you don't
take step one unless you know where
you're gonna land on
step two so uh so
so i i i i get your point i i
to to come back to a question if we did
drive the census down further
it sounds to me like we've structured
the services
and the personnel that support them in a
way in which
we might still not be driving down costs
much
i mean we could we could get to near
zero and still
have a pretty hefty bill right
yeah i think some hard decisions are
going to have to be made about what some
of those fixed costs are in terms of
educational programming you know
food service um medical programming you
know i
like i said i'm not comfortable with
eliminating 24 7 nursing but
you know you to drive down costs those
are the kinds of things that people are
going to have to wrestle with
which you know are not things that i'd
be comfortable
recommending the elimination of um
i do think that you know by structuring
a new program we could probably be more
thoughtful about how staffing could be
used in a different setup
you know right now with a lot of space
to cover staff you know we're covering
different units that hold
large number of kids so you might be
able to gain some some efficiencies
through different structures of the
of the units through developing a new a
new um
program and i think that um you know
reduced census
like i said it's not just the census
it's it's the units
so it's it's about figuring out i think
as representative wallner said before
what do we do to to treat girls if we
know that there's only going to be
at most a couple girls in the program
i think that there's you know it would
be difficult to say there's no option
for the girl in the state of new
hampshire
but maybe there's a way to think
differently about what that looks like
there are things that can be done but
it's it is very complex and it's
hard to do in the absence of knowing
what the impacts of our current reforms
are going to date i know that's not
satisfactory to a lot of folks but
i'm not particularly comfortable making
a prediction on exactly what these small
numbers are going to be
in future years until we see the impact
of some of the reforms that are
thank you for that are there are there
any other questions i don't see any from
the committee
any from the attendees uh
i had one thing to that chair where are
you oh go ahead
thank you um so one thing i would just
mention in every legislative committee
that has looked at this
of course evaluates this as well but i
think it's something that has
uh made it difficult from a return on
investment standpoint to build a new
facility is that when this building is
no longer used for this purpose
there is a potential 10 million dollar
payback to the federal government
that um was part of how the building was
paid for when it was built
so that's something we didn't talk about
specifically in the presentation but i
think it's
most people know that um but i wanted to
mention it
so that it's not forgotten well most
people
knew that and but i didn't so i
appreciate
you telling me thank you
um all right well it's
it's been a it's it's been to me a
productive day
maybe it was a little more brutal than
what you imagined when you came in this
morning mr ribson but i
i i really uh appreciate you coming up
from new jersey with all your experience
and all you've invested into
improving our dcyf program i i
think your your leadership is well
recognized
and that you have an incredible
reputation
and so so if you can help us put
together that
that tough love decision on what to do
with this facility
that would be that would be truly a
great thing
so and i i believe i believe you have it
in you if you can just you know let us
know
with that um mr ripple
uh oh did i already say to the committee
members i sent you an email this morning
asking you about
uh next week's work sessions please take
a look at that
and respond i really need that
information from you
um and with that mr ripple am i
forgetting something
i don't think so okay
and i don't need a motion to adjourn
right i can just say
all right all right well i think uh with
that we're adjourned thank you
monday
you